Queen six-inch five queer chicks h5
problem book mate find it find it find
it oh my gosh I love it I love it
that makes me had I love it makes me
happy because not every day you get a
position where all the sudden those
tactical patterns you've been working on
since a wee youngin right
that's a wee lad you were a real ad
remember how I taught you in a chess
camp one time
[Music]
and then we had Sergey Karjakin one of
last year's semi-finalists finally get
to his first-round matchup today against
the one the only the Polish fighter 3000
is he's now becoming known on chest comm
Yann Christophe Duda with me as always
Grand Master Robert Hess his mother just
texted me privately and said make sure
you call him Bobby today so I'm just
making sure I'm doing what your mom
asked me to do Bobby as we look at this
matchup tell me what you think you know
there's a big question mark next to
young Christoph due to a very very
talented player in classical chess of
course he went +1 in Dortmund earlier
this year he became the Polish number
one player of course we'll see him at
the Olympiad but karyakin is a well
known commodity in the chess circles
he's been one of the top list players
for a long time now in fact he's
probably the most feared player after
Magus Carlsen along there with MBL
Hikaru Nakamura but I think kuryakin's
proven himself time and time again
except big exception was at the sync
field no sleep obscuring the st. Louis
blitz tournament where he underperformed
for the first time what feels like
forever but in this format and speed
Chess Championship I mean he's proven
himself to be an absolute monster yeah
he has and even Hikaru Nakamura who I
think is considered by many to be the
favorite especially with Magnus Carlsen
on the field this year and probably
considers himself the favorite if a car
was honest he said that he feels like in
a matchup with Sergey it's really a
50/50 shot of course we're not here to
talk about later matchups in this year
species championship right right now
we're here to talk about the matchup
against the Polish rising superstar very
young tell us a little bit about Yann
Christophe Duda and why maybe this
underdog has an outside fighter chance
here against the the Russian Minister of
Defense well absolutely
he's currently ranked 23rd in the world
in classical chess 2739 he recently
leapfrogged his compatriot why Taj ik so
that's some very impressive cuz what
object needs to just force in the chests
are good for a long time and well do
does very consistent as of late you know
it sometimes with young players you see
them go up to near 2750 and drop back
down
they happen to richard report but it's
not happening to do too as of yet again
he profound +1 in dortmund and create
performance he has in recent months then
playing quite a deal of chess he played
the chinese super tournament finishing
to even score against a very strong
field so i've been very impressed by his
level of consistency in this past year
and you know he does do very well
against lower rated competition he does
struggle a bit against players that are
in the upper echelon but then again who
doesn't so car yakin who had a really
big difficulties in st. louis both in
the rapid and bliss portions and then
especially in the Sinquefield cup while
he has his work cut out from today it
gets a young and rising superstar of
chess well said and let's remind
everybody who for some reason may or may
not be aware of the format of the speech
has championship you're looking at a the
most exciting event that happens in
online chess where we get all of these
elite grandmasters to play in a bracket
style knockout tournament the winner of
each match obviously moves on to the
next round we have three plus hours of
chess with 90 minutes of five-minute 60
minutes of three-minute and then on to
at the last half an hour being one
minute one thing to remember is what
they're playing for of course the prizes
increase with each round all the matches
is about 16,000 in prizes for the first
round but that gets bigger each round
considering there are less players
competing for each prize pool and of
course there's always the option that
fans throw throw some cash their way
during each match for things they'd like
to see we're about to about to jump in
here with sergei Kuryakin versus young
Kristoff do you know but remember we
have a lot of other matches throughout
the year all 16 of these faces many of
them have already played a few of them
have already been sent packing but
tomorrow is the big one we have onigiri
taken on chakra our mom at Yara I think
that many people had this date of
September 7th circled on their calendar
a long time ago today they're being the
excitement that goes the other way and
the fact that we have a huge favorite to
win the whole thing like circa Kuryakyn
and then a big underdog we'll see what
the young Polish man is capable of but
tomorrow
Robert Geary versus mama Yara I mean it
is a it is anybody's coin flip I cannot
wait to see what happens there before
the game star
while I have everyone's attention I want
to remind you that one of the most
exciting events on chefs comm that
involves all different levels of chess
players will be starting very soon in
September the season two of the
streamer's championship will get
underway
and of course we have even bigger prizes
more events and all kinds of stuff
people like Grand Master Robert Hess
will be there so that's all you need to
know and looks like our players are
ready Robert I'm ready the chat is ready
shout out to chess Bay Sela Bethel and M
but uh everyone I can see liquid IDI
product we already have Nathan f3 one
for with a sub just I'm pumped I'm ready
are you ready I'm you know I I'm
definitely ready for the match I'm just
unsure what's about to happen really I
love that these two players are meeting
up in the first round I think that I've
seen them in the chat that a lot of
people are very happy that Duda was
invited and will be playing because
again he's one of those players
27:40 fidei perhaps his blitz and rapid
skills not up to his classical skills at
the moment I think his blitz rating just
leaves him just outside top 50 in the
world but of course an incredible talent
and one that you know this could be good
experience for him as he rises towards
the tip of the absolute tippy top of
chess it will be good experience in
playing cardiac in game after game in a
three hour match yeah I mean a lot of
people of course we talk a lot about who
the next world champion will be of
course we have a world championship
match this year which you and I will be
covering every day here on Twitch but
more on that later
but you know if you're talking about who
the next generation of stars are young
Christophe Duda hasn't been mentioned as
much among some of the other names if
you talk about Wei Yi there's who else
would I would I be thinking of that I
feel like young Christophe maybe hasn't
get been given as much love or his due
of the fact that he's very very young
super super talented and certainly
someone who's on his way to the top to
the top tippy top so alright well
they're ready I've been told the games
are going to be starting here
momentarily we we there they are
once and for all have lift-off Robert
you look good today buddy you look like
you've already gotten your exercise so
thanks for doing that
well you know that I walked over three
miles today so you you know that I'm
trying to stay in shape to compensate in
this game we have a Sicilian of the
first game so how can we not be ready
for an exciting battle and Polish
fighter as you mentioned I love that
username and G for karyakin whoa gar I
can not as not as much of a rating
differentials I would have expected
considering how strong Kuryakin is but
then again he's been maybe not as been
as frequent on the side here he goes G
for g5 taking over that d5 scored Danny
yeah I know you love playing Sicilians
with both colors don't you absolutely
and this is this is one of the more
challenging lines and I was just about
to say that one of the things you get at
least as far as the type of games that
happen when you have this big underdog
matchup Robert is I don't think that the
Polish fight or 3,000 young Christophe
is gonna be holding anything back right
he wants he knows he needs to play home
cooking prep he's gonna really try to
challenge Corey Aachen because that's
his best chance to he wants to bring his
best chess here you know no no secrets
being kept well there might be some
secrets because I see guides and nice go
says Duda is playing from the polish
national team training camp with
preparing for the Olympia it's what you
think so you know maybe he can't reveal
all that he's doing with the team but we
will see what he has in store in this
game and a 95 move for some that may
seem well it's strangers an item b6 that
can now capture it but as you see here
look at this pawn structure four and
three on the queenside for white the a
through DZ files and what that means is
why would love to play c4 c5 and start
pushing forward that said the knight on
b3 some see that as a good piece that
just now controls the position for
example if you take on e5 and the night
takes 95 then then I can just go right
to d4 but in the other hand you really
want to have that pawn on b4 with your
knight mp3 so you could play c4 c5 and
so do duh playing extremely quickly like
clearly just comfortable in the black
side of the Sicilian and it's a tough
choice for cardiac and round he does
take that pollen e5 and what I was about
to say was it frees up the d4 sport for
your pieces but it also lets that night
gain access to the position from d7 it
was more of a defensive piece now can be
more aggressive ideas with Bishop c4
Queen d7 coming to come to my
I would start with Queen d7 here that
way I can decide later hey do I want to
put my bishop on h3 or don't playing
Bishop g4 trading off those bishops and
that way my maid my bishop won't get
into any trouble and a third option of
course is just putting that bishop back
to the g6 square where it's perfectly
safe and sound and controls a good
diagonal and the White King Danny where
is that going because we Castle
queenside rook c8 is the immediate idea
that comes to mind well I think you have
to anyway at some point because of this
at this juncture I was just about to say
you're about to get overwhelmed having
to guard both g5 and d5 but Sergei finds
an aggressive way to do it gaining a
temp on the bishop and then reinforcing
the Jeep on but but I don't know I guess
I'm a little more skeptical of blacks
position maybe maybe being a bias that
playing these types of English attacks
many times one of the things to notice
is that white is worried about the c2
pawn but if you can get castled and
there's no immediate threats where is
blacks long-term pressure coming outside
of white rushing things like h5 this
move like Knight d4 is strong and if
black ever pushes to be pawn then the c6
where it becomes weak I like 94 just
from the perspective that a guards both
c2 and has all these aggressive
intentions in mind but okay the the
counter play for black is the pressures
on now he's got to come up with
something where's where's the next move
is he is he trying to stop the attack
with things like f6 at some point
although now it's not possible because
e6 is being spied or is there is there
something else for black well this is a
large reason why I like them Queen d7
earlier because of protect that Bishop
a5 and allowed you to avoid this idea of
h4 it I mean h5 from black I guess he's
hoping that if G takes h6 on pass on
Bishop takes h4 check that's enough
counter play given the fact that your
king is about to open up if I'm white do
I play a move like Knight f5 but then I
think well Knight a5 Bishop f5 rook on
g6 and black is in time to defend the
king side that said why does have the
two bishops that could be in a long-term
advantage and b3 I think is a very nice
decision because why play Knight a5 the
visual on g6 not going anywhere
by playing b3 I stopped your knife
come to c4 I can play see for myself you
don't want to play b5 is black because
that's met by pawn a for breaking open
the queenside pawn structure and leaving
a 6 or weakness and well forever a
target probably just winning upon so I
think black things are starting to go
wrong for black here whereas after Queen
d7 I thought it was a little bit more
flexibility and here maybe 7 the Queen
can come to h3 I think it's a little bit
too little and a little bit too late
over/under those who bet under 10
minutes before we heard a Karl I'm out
outside Robert's window they have now
officially taken home that Vegas prop
bet and we move on yeah you know
sometimes the ambulance got to go but we
thought we would like to believe that
wherever that ambulance is headed it's
more important than this chess match so
we'll forgive the sirens yeah absolutely
and okay so Bishop d8 this is not what
you want from the black side I mean
you're you have quite a passive said
even though this bishop rear adds up to
b6 which i think is a good idea with the
opponent's e2 being spied on Knight a5
always a timely response here and you
know if we trade on e3 Bishop takes c3
I can't consider playing Knight takes
and I think you do want to play Knight
takes c3 because I was about to say the
one thing that could happen if black
took on e3 and then black was able to
trade on f5 and follow that by g6 you
have this sort of good knight on e5
versus it's potentially not the best
bishop on e2 so so I think that black is
probably needing to to go that route yep
yeah I'm looking for rook f6 file but
Queen b6 just trying to get after that
d6 pawn so if I'm black I might I was
about to say throwing a move like rook
c5 or Queen c7 he plays rook c5 hitting
d5 now and if I play b4 as white rook
takes d5 I can't go c4 which would trap
your rook under normal circumstances but
the fact of the matter is there's a move
like rook c8 or pinning that pawn on c4
ISM king b2 now
c4 is meant by b5 so what about Brooke
takes d5 here is that not a free pawn so
rip d5 maybe pawn c4 look back to see if
I'm in rook d1 is the intention inning
d6 threatening Queen takes e5 of your 5
moves away so
yeah things have not gone precisely
kuryakin's where I thought he had a
pretty nice position but now it's
counterplay clearly for for black hello
Dan you do not play Brooke v to c6 here
as again that blenders a knight on e5
so yeah I agree the way this has gone
has has made me feel better and better
about young Christoph's position the
knight to me a potentially better piece
than the bishop here in the endgame even
though maybe normally that's not always
the case the fact that there's targets
on the dark squares here and and this
Knight has already centralized people I
think are often biased to the fact that
in open Center end games or an end games
with pawns on both sides of the board
the bishop should be better but if you
have a centralized knight that's almost
never never totally one-sided and so
looking at the way this game is going
you start to feel like young Christoph
is now in a position where things like
b5 and even d5 are screaming to be
played let's pry open the C file and get
jiggy with it right Robert I mean what
about a move like d5 or b5 here I like
ya and d5 actually is it pretty nicely I
can move because a pawn takes you look
at the e-file so maybe there's rooks he
to check followed by we trade everything
on c2 then I'm Knight d7 hitting both of
rook and f6 and the mission 1 e2 and
that should give should have given black
quite an advantage yeah interesting
he went with b5 there Robert um to back
up the analysis I mean I think you were
totally right that d5 I thought it was
half a dozen one of the other but I
admit I forgot the palm is hanging on d6
which of course the Minister of Defense
did not but let's look at this at
blackhat played d5
I think he was in in total control here
of where this game was going too late
now though and I'm a little concerned
about blacks position here actually
because it seems the what is up upon we
just paused for a second and blacks
little pawn but you cannot play pawn
takes B 3 because rook takes e5 and the
important point about that is that sir
rook seats you check the official when
t2 is protected by the rook on e5 so you
couldn't get away with that
tactical sequence now black is coming
after the h4 pawn but is that on more
valuable than the a6 on the reason why I
say no is that once this Bishop gets on
that long diagonal you stop you both
stop the black pawn from queening you
cover the h1 square and you can protect
the a
queening square at the same time and
this proves the dominance of bishop
overnight and so Knight III check forces
the minor piece up the board 93 check
King takes c3 Knight takes d4 pawn takes
c4 the big problem for black even
material but White's pawn is better
quality pawns for white as a passed pawn
there black has trouble creating a
passed pawn himself so it took on h4 but
I think this is a really bad ending for
blood this has been quite the turnaround
honestly from where that game was headed
with blacks opportunity to play d5 the
dude amidst to where we're headed now
where suddenly what was a dead equal
position on the clock is now a nearly
two minute time advantage for cardiac on
in addition to everything you
highlighted the be pawns gonna be a pass
or even if the a pawn Falls and in c3 is
just not something that black and defend
long term in fact any White's just gonna
take it now Bishop d3 might even be a
nice move to throw in here the point is
that for h4 I can take on that Oh
actually I can't do that I was trying to
take on that five like rook aged six and
then black had worked h8 and no that
would have worked out for yeah I think
he could I don't think you're wrong
about that but I think it's almost
picking between Flavor Flav's at this
point because I believe that Kuryakin is
on his on his way and those who bet the
first unnecessary pop culture reference
from me would come in less than 15
minutes and they went that prop that so
there you go it's a 93 now Nathan hit
the bishop anther a 95 check but I guess
a 6 would have been played he has nice
c2 check coming here as well though it's
a little tricky this sure but nicely to
check there's King a4 with safety so
what's he doing here he's allowing the
Queen Mab in and saying maybe I can well
there's there are some opportunities for
a sort of fortress looking thing here a
7 king of 680 plan maybe Knight f5 but
now this is I mean it's highly unlikely
but it's a it's a swindle worth trying
because it is blitz but in this
situation if the clocks were reversed
and Corey Aachen had 4 seconds maybe it
works but given that dude is the one
down on the clock I doubt Sergei blows
this yep so b4 here I mean you can just
give up as bishop for the h-bond and
push your own beep on the knight and
rook or a bad duo in positions like this
because the knight has trouble getting
back towards the
on whereas a bishop is much better
suited for reaching reaching pieces that
are farther away just inherent their
peace movement so now the okay I think
he can almost take the H pawn and give
up the bishop one if one I was thinking
there might be Queenie seven and then
the King moves in a queen to f8 check
picking up the knight on f1 but okay
maybe maybe that was unnecessary
according to Sergei yep I mean but I'm
go ahead no I was gonna say you said
unnecessary but I said speaking of
unnecessary tone-deaf says all Danny
pop-culture references are necessary
thank you there you go there you go and
wow this is gonna be a fun made on h7
young Kristoff doesn't allow it but the
mate coming to h7 with the knight being
pinned would have been our first oMG
emote of the day mate did not happen and
instead cardiac can takes it home but as
the next game gets started and we we
follow that here just really I'm gonna
back up this analysis board while I have
the ability to do so and just go back to
that position where d5 could have been
played Robert and it was just really
almost a +3 advantage according to the
engine for black if you play d5 instead
of e5 you think that maybe the young
Polish man just wasn't expecting to have
that kind of chance he might even be a
little bit nervous at this point given
that he knows he's going up against one
of the favorites you buy in that theory
that that's why he missed d5 III really
yeah I would have to imagine he missed
it
rather than he just chose not to play it
because right such a strong move
opening up the position even more so I
don't know if it's nerves he's he's 20
years old he's right there's nothing to
be nervous but he's incredibly strong
but I think he just it's just an
oversight and we'll see if he's able to
rebound from it I do not like the fact
that we are seeing on Berlin and the
reason why I like oh the reason why I
don't love it is not because I find the
Berlin boring actually quite to the
contrary from the Berlin to be very
interesting there's always nuances I'm
so glad you said that I feel like I
thought I was alone I also like the
Berlin you think that's why your mom
knows that we're so compatible you think
that's it no I think it's just the
ridiculous pop culture reference yeah
okay and here though the reason why I'm
not such a big fan of it is because if I
think about people who play the Brillion
all the time Sergei karyakin obviously
comes to mind he's playing in all these
elite tournaments the Berlin is a very
popular opening at that level and
Kuryakin has tremendous experience
defending positions that some may not
enjoy playing and right now with black
I'm not seeing the issue here you have
double pop the main feature of the
Berlin these CC pods White has a
three-on-two majority on the kingside
but those pods can't move if you add g4
you always want a knight to go into the
h4 square with check right now this III
admit that the last game happened so
fast and I was highlighting maybe dude
is missed opportunity five that I didn't
see it but this looks like one of the
better Berlin's we've seen in awhile I
mean here the things that black is
supposed to have in terms of
compensation for these CC pawns Robert
is hopeful d-file control in this case
he even has this rook lift on e6 which
is threatening to pop over to b6 or a
six at a moment's notice to poke at
these pawns and white is supposed to
have a mobile three-on-two majority not
a stuck three on to that allows things
like not h4 so what went wrong here so
early for Duda on the white side of the
Berlin well you know I don't want to go
so far say things are going totally
wrong but you know he played when these
setups where it's not as forceful I
guess he allowed black to sort of
control the board by playing H 5 H 4 and
then the rook came to d8 unchallenged he
was able to take back on e6 with the
rook rather than the pond
that's not always a bad thing from the
from White's perspective because take on
e6 to the pawn often fortifies the
position it does make it more majority
for white on the extreme right side of
the board on the Kings side with G and H
was just G but here I think the white is
still doing quite fun everything is
defended the c4 pawn can be attacked
with more legwork to e4 em I think
that's coming soon just once you would
play h5 you can then play g4 for white
so I think that
Duda should be quite happy that he is
controlling the board and you know I
think Kuryakin at this stage of the game
right now I think that he's been pushed
back and it's his threats have been
pared he is gonna go b5 before and maybe
try to make progress over there but at
the same time I
I like the move h5 yeah and I like g4 to
follow it ok you convinced me I
overreacted I guess and I admit that
night f2 was really a key move to kind
of start the pushback not only did it
remove the rook from d3 but opened up
that option you were highlighting that
black has to constantly be careful of a
rook to e4 hitting the c4 pawn so g5 is
played and Bishop c1 I like that move
you know why why trade on g6 when your
opponent has just given you a past H
pawn right Harry you're about to become
a wizard on a chain yeah I mean this is
um this is this is looking like it may
be a potential rebound here for the for
the Polish youngster yep and trying to
figure out a the exact way to progress
here because Knight g4 is one of those
moves that's very tempting when a point
is a pawn in g5 and you can't kick my
knight away I like putting my name in g4
I don't and I could play pawn g4 but but
but then you give up the h4 square right
yes that's exactly what I'm concerned
about no I like your move Knight g4
night and I think even just from the
perspective that it threatens h6 and a
lot of positions right I mean there's
also this outside plan of bringing the
King up to f3 in chief or I mean that
seems weird let's not let's not get the
King mated but okay the idea you
highlighted earlier I guess I forgot
that
efore was open and and here comes the c4
pawn being targeted this looks like a
nice move from Duda yeah and actually
you know there are many different
options here one night h3 is also
possible because now you can't go g4 is
blacks and that h3 might pick up that g5
on hmm how do you defend it nigt I guess
your rip de 3 as a response hit my g3
pawn so I don't want to move that night
away too soon and perhaps that's why he
didn't play Knight g4 because then
Brooke d3 would have been an option as
well that night perhaps belongs in the
e4 square where it both his g5 but you
feel like if there was some way to
remove this night from f5 without having
to play chief or uh that's why I like
this idea of king of three kimchi for
there's even maybe rook f1 in some
positions where then Knight g4 is coming
with tempo on the night I feel like if
this Knight has to move and you didn't
have to commit G for a lot more roads
open up right both the H pawn rushing up
the board may be threats of
right as I say that he decides the h4
squared doesn't worry him I was about to
recommend the move rook h1 and get whoa
997 typically you don't see a knight go
to that square with a pass on you mean
you're not in a fee in Catalan euro
Knights I am sometimes when it is a
passed pawn there I'm worried about age
six and then just you can't stop me oh
dang but two rook takes e4 rook takes
four h6 yeah look how crazy that would
be everyone look at this combination on
a nail my word that might work
h6 King moves h7 holy shenanigans Robert
I don't like the eval bar very much but
in this case it proves your genius was
correct white would be winning if he
goes for this amazing sack he don't for
it I think if it aged six you would end
up in rook c6 back and then white had
rook h1 so I mean that was definitely a
possibility they're out here here since
the roof would have had to come back he
it's harder to do it now because rook c4
works for 86 now the rook the B Brooke
can retreat so yeah maybe look at you
did you did you eat your Wheaties this
morning yeah no actually you saw the US
Open yesterday so you're practically a
scientist I was at the US Open I saw
Novak Djokovic was John Newman and
Madison keys and Carlos Suarez Navarro
so I had a good time
Wow no but I mean seriously that was a
nice find it's an interesting shot to
keep in mind when we have Harry the the
H pond over there looming just a few
squares away and honestly an instructive
tactic for those always wanting to learn
from these matches this idea of of just
how dangerous a passed pawn can be and
honestly how how useless a knight can be
at stopping pass pawns right Robert
that's why accommodations like that work
and tactics trainer so absolutely and
here so things have been settled a bit
f5 played so if you played G takes at
five rook takes a five comes with check
the h5 pawn well it's still an outside
passed pawn I can just retreat my king
say to g2 and try to work that pawn
forward hmm but I also don't have to
take on if I there's no real reason to
because my I have protected outside
passed pawn if you take on g4 I'll just
take back with my knight and make some
progress over Bishop e3 looks like a
good move
and f4 don't love that idea I think you
need to be able to capture in g4 and not
leave white with a protective passed on
and so that's why king f7 was played but
how to move forward for black egg and
try to go King g7 King h6 that looks
like a sort of difficult task to have
and by playing Brookes e6 there it opens
up ideas of GTA except 5 to remove the
rooks protection of that g6 night so so
far I'm not sure who what I mean is I
was wondering if it was white in a
position to maybe take on a5 there and
after Brooke takes King g4 you couldn't
play king of 6 because 94 check I didn't
know why it didn't make sense to be a
little more forceful in taking on a5 and
play king g4 but I mean I think white is
still in the driver's seat with this H
pawn anyway but but it's looking harder
for white to make progress yeah although
this was a looks like a pretty nice
defensive resource from for car yakin
because 95 check is good you don't want
to take on e5 because I'm the he walks
into the face of danger discovered check
Bologna wait is 93 check allowing Knight
takes d4 that's why yeah that was that
was something but nicéphore chapel same
good check it's a gut and play by car
you can yo now a5 is hanging d6 is
hanging so please okay so now ok there's
threats of bish before so don't hang
your rook okay he say 5 he could've just
taken on a5 I include if you're right he
goes for it the second time around but
you're right he might regret losing that
tempo and there goes the Jeep ammonite
c4 you can always bend 94 to try to
trade off those that knife for the
bishop but this is looking good for
Corey akan again suddenly it is that the
taker is so quickly here each one mate
so don't poke blunders made of King Fe
hikakin sees it at the last second
backing up says whoa Nelly
now this is again this is like
transitioning into yeah who's better now
the ape owner of the Jeep on nicely for
threatens both protects and threatens to
take d6
so maybe for kh3 now if we gauge 393 you
get king h2 in time and don't get made
it now by black is it should be winning
this yes suddenly suddenly the bishop is
flexing its open board muscles over the
night you can see it takes away all
these squares the one thing we haven't
really highlighted Robert in the in our
analysis of these two games is that both
players seem to be equal for the most
part throughout most the middle game on
the clock and then suddenly in these end
games it's like they're both at two
minutes and young Christoph goes way
down on the clock did correctly just
blunder though he just muttered he
blowed out takes up four check right as
I was highlighting the time and he could
have won King g3 and won the rook but
instead he thought that he was winning
but he forgot about rope checking behind
and this is my gosh that is suddenly
White's winning
yup King eh 393 just take that pawn off
the board give up you're a pawn for the
cheap on yes winning and something
interesting to note and our stat man my
client mentioned it to me that this is a
second straight game where Kuryakin and
rook and Bishop versus rook and Knight
in the second straight game where he was
out playing Duda with rook and Bishop
versus working nights and now that's the
kind of stat that's gonna come back
throughout this match as far as the way
the type of pieces these players favor
yeah but this is okay this is a no
brainer now and cardiac and greatly
regretting for those wanting to check
out the analysis board it just it all
started right back here g2 was not the
losing move giving up the bishop with
cheque was okay everyone I'll bring up
the next game but the move had to be
king the III came to g3 here and black
maintains the threat although actually
Robert in that position there would have
been Knight e3 and if g1 rook g4 yeah I
thought you'd win you what you wasn't
rough but you're probably not winning I
mean if the trade happens in white has
Knight d5 absolutely in agreement and I
think at that point cardiac can had
already thrown away his winning
advantage he could have done g2 earlier
instead of moving bishop that for
because trading on the knife and Bishop
wouldn't have helped white stop pawn
from promoting so he missed his
opportunity and now we see an
interesting position once more we
started into Sicilian
and this time in a Bishop b5 check the
sign and what we see on the board is
that both sides of equal material white
has is very clear two on one on the a
and B files black has the superior
center in terms of number of ponds but
it's very difficult for black off in the
plates move pawn to d6 in d5 and the
reason why this idea with before is so
good for white is there's no a 7-pound
to go to a6 y okay wait b5 and then I
will stay there forever saying you're
never pushing you're a pawn is in d6 a
week and you're not pushing your D pawn
because i have firm control over the d5
square yep so a very clear idea for
white is to eventually a for Ben to play
a 5 then to play a move like Knight a 4
and put a piece on d6 and that's why
black when active here with 95 because
my knight wants to go to c4 it might not
be able to stay there for so long but in
that NC 4 is quite an annoying piece so
Knight a 4 just stops 9 c4 in its tracks
and that night is coming right to the b6
where I'm like this reminds me of a
Russian schoolboy lesson I was given by
Uncle your mode some point where
basically if White has this two on one
and black can't get d5 and to try to
change the structure these positions are
just almost positionally winning for
white right because as you highlight it
there's no way to get rid of the minors
on the Queen side and whites just gonna
use access to these squares and
eventually advance the a pawn and again
black has to find some way to either
make counter play on the C firework or
change the whole nature of the structure
by opening the center with d5 and if you
can't you're just positionally busted
yep that's a very good point and now
this lady's rear adds up to b2 which
once more is an awkward place to be
we've seen in this night you know no but
I think he's going for the plain you
highlight I think he wants the a pawn to
lead the way bring that pony back behind
and then enter into b6 yep and so from
black do I just play brick a to c8 here
and say well I'm gonna you may try to
push that pawn on a file but I'm gonna
try to take control of it I think either
that or he has to try for d5 I mean we
can calculate the fact that one of the
issues with 94 we didn't point out as
you said previously d5 wasn't possible
but but it might be possible now defy
I'm always concerned with a queen on d8
with a rook facing me on the you know
over t1 so that's that's something that
concerns it might be
good but now you're right d5 even like
rook seeded you want to avoid the trade
that's a good point Robert yeah it just
feels a little bit iffy at the moment
and okay I think Duda going to think
here makes perfect sense he's doing fine
in the clock but you did a great job
Danny pointing out that it seems like
things are level and all of a sudden we
looking at the time and Duda has 15
seconds left
yes that's what's happened a few times
right they were level level level about
the two and a half minute mark is when
suddenly you see Kuryakin has gained a
big edge on the clock
and there goes d5 okay he goes for it
but I think rook seeded d1 I mean that
was the move that you highlighted and I
think it was a great point it's a good
lesson for all Sicilian players if and
when you can get d5 safely tactically
it's often a change in the structure the
favors black especially in dragons where
it opens up the bishop and you've
already got the C file so the D file
helps but if it doesn't work tactically
then d5 is a move that really can
backfire interesting Bishop d4 was
played I think that's also cool because
if the knight moves for me five we have
E 5 and then F for reinforcing a big
space advantage yup and you've limit the
nice that's do you know I mean you're
saying in another way by having a
spatial advantage you limit your
opponent's pieces so yeah I hear like
you could play e5 allow the knight to
capture in d4 and try to play out for
afterwards the only issue I see if
Knight takes d4 it ever happens instead
of this well there's always Queen b6
pinning and there's Queen b6 check
picking up tonight on b5 I guess your
rook c5 no Queen b6 rooks you got Knight
d4 comes into play so sneaky Robert
Queen b6 King h1 now I can take on b5
when you take on c6
I need to evaluate that and I'm not sure
how to but it feels like it feels like
Sergey missed his chance against e5 I
still liked your rook to c2 c2 d1 better
than Bishop d4 but if he takes me five
and white takes c6 maybe even just take
back isn't my bishop
kind of a nice piece against that night
on b2 I mean looks like we're gonna find
out because he's going for that line so
I think I think B takes c6 here you
don't want to take on be too because
likely white takes on b7 with tempo
right
all right so I would take Neal beats hc6
here of course makes sense and if I'm
white you don't wanna play for too soon
because by doing so I actually so
weakened both my a and B poncho I want
to force black people I played it I said
I wanted to force blacks start attacking
my pawns first but I guess if you're
gonna play
I'm with like 93 your beaver pond is
safe and sound
yo Stewart got a queen to chief if the
Queen goes to b6 maybe you go nice c4
with tempo and then keep going so okay
that mean goes to g5 I spy with my
little eye
but isn't this e6 pawn hanging well then
right Bishop b2 queen miss you Brooke
take safe loss okay yeah
oh but I get neither on the back no yes
matin bake but Brooke c6 Queen d2 that
way I'd make you first in the back rank
I guess maybe hopefully you can make me
any telling the the fans have been
donating based on the blunders and the
brilliance ease they've seen so far
Robert so that's been kind of fun so uh
well try it we'll try to read some
messages when the when the when the tips
come in for these players so we can
remember some good messages that maybe
comes with a donation to tell them after
the match so we appreciate everyone's
support and thank you to all 2000 of you
that are with us already
the match has just begun it's the only
just begun to live yep there we go we're
on the same page named rookie Danni
sneaky move because b5 Queen takes b5
happens and that's tactics back rank
problems get some don't jump and now he
even just brings the Queen to b5
straight up h3 wait what Oh h3 then
Queen B if I'm sorry I missed the move
order while analyzing because here the
otherwise the white rook would be
hanging yep but okay yeah this is uh I
mean it seems like do two held his own
they're the middlegame transition he's
not down on the clock in the same way he
was previously we might be getting our
first we've already had a win for each
player in this match we might be about
to get our first peaceful result of the
match here this looks very peaceful and
I'm trying to even think which of these
two players would be playing for win
here I guess white because Queen B for
Brooks a check that's a blunder waiting
to happen and note that the black
has no escaping on the back rank so if
you take on before Brooksie a check
remove the guard of the Queen um before
and picks up the Queen for a row and
that said there are still times and
that's a fortress Oh
where you looking for bonds can hold off
a queen and three but here I there's no
reason to even think about things like
that lady five and Krakens still was
hoping for instead of King g7 move like
Queen takes before whatever once again
allowed for CA check-in the women
material so to show that tactic for
everybody that's an overwhelming ruk
would be winning the Queen so there you
go now he's gonna take five with Chuck
and I wouldn't be surprised if we just
get a draw offer here and a and Anita
shake of the hands moving on as they say
well honestly I was a little worried
after that first game Robert that he do
to blue where he was really much better
potentially as black in the night or if
that this could be the start of a really
rough outing but he not only recovered
with a win for all intents and purposes
he kind of outplayed his opponents there
with the with the black pieces right I
mean right now Duda is holding his own
as he takes a sip of what hopefully is
lemonade and not something else well you
know that way you know that Joe caught
me off guard then it's hard to catch me
off guard with you but that one really
got me in here we see another nighter
but this time was corey acting on the
ice so do you think that kraken didn't
like his berlin and decided to go for
the sicilian and what what goes under
his I mean I I you heard my initial
reaction although I feel like you saw
the position deeper than I did I thought
black got a fine Berlin there but over
time due to did unwind and eventually
use the kingside pawns with this H pawn
he might have even missed your brilliant
combination of sacking the brook to win
so I guess cardiac and it and he decides
but you know it's also early enough in
the match that I personally think the
strategy we've seen where players are
poking and prodding maybe finding
something they like for as the time
controls get faster then they can speed
up and and maybe put their opponent or
pressure in a position that they felt
comfortable with right yeah maybe he's
just maybe right now he's just pokin and
proddin but to me it's interesting
because Duda
is the night of black so I don't know if
I'd be as willing to play at the whites
the black side of a position that my
opponent likes to play you're looking do
to go Knight a5 always a very annoying
move to face yeah when you're playing
Network because you can't move your beep
on without light of the night to come to
c6 yeah and now white is going forward
with the plan that I mentioned in the
other game well this is a really
important structure to know whenever
you're playing Knight Orff's that
involve castles on both sides of the
port this this is sort of a classical
type of structure if anyone wants to
look up a game Geller Fischer where FM
Geller who had a great record against
Fischer for those who don't know that I
actually really really put on a nice
show of how to use this Queen side
structure so go ahead and go to chess
Gamescom check out Geller Fischer and
you're welcome for that little pro tip
but efore okay this is the way black
gets compensation hopefully he wanted
the e5 square and and due to said no
thank you and played f4 so but know this
this is a structure that I really like
for white robber because if white can
close down the king side here comes a
four eventually even bring back the
night either choose between a 5 and c5
and white just has a positional grind no
this is looking
I hate these positions from the black
side yep and you know first say kudos EU
for the great historical reference I'm a
big fan of history and chess and you you
gave the fans what they needed to know
Geller Fischer 1-0 go look it up right
now
I I know the game you're talking about I
also know that Geller I think at a
plus-two school you know a lot of people
out you know you remember the great
champions where a good they war but it's
it's like course you know he had a great
record against towel
right and Geller really owned Fischer
that was the truth no other way to say
it well you know I true to power and
let's see these pawns well speaking of
power pawn on d6 which is protected by a
pawn on c5 and so g3 played hoping to
get some sort of attack if you play put
on take c3 then Knight g4 Queen if I
would win Age 3 look at that just Knight
look at the Polish fighter here he just
he's putting the minister of defense in
a position where he's got to earn his
name here because carry akka is just
worse again the super impressive play
right now yep Age 3 is just a smart move
because you did not want
Knight to Linden g4 yep we're both is
advancing in the position but also
allowing black to start thinking about
check meaning white on the edge file so
now what it's just
okay so Brooke gave one dozen I was
gonna say this rupee one and then bring
the other work over that was the first
thing that it was he gonna play and rook
be one Queen d3 me and then I take I can
take on d3 and take on oh that's what he
wants of rook me one Queen III Queen
takes d3 pawn takes d3 as it is rook
takes b7 there was ninety five hitting
the bishop on III and then there's still
like different way but there's Bishop D
for coming and c5 is undermined so dude
it went the safer out of just putting
the rook on d1
I mean now it looks like he can just
take on b7 with the night which will
guard c5 yeah and he does it and the c6
is met by Queen even Knight back to a5 a
queen d5 is always an option as well you
know this this looks very Wayne sorry I
just saw if I'm a little violet wish got
my cosmic says Danny I like him so this
is mostly just fun teasing but he looks
like he would own a vape shop and be
very involved I love the very involved
part i I don't even know that I get it
but I know how to laugh at jokes even
when I don't get it kind of like a
two-year-old as she learns humor she
knows when the timing is right but she
doesn't get it you know
yeah we mean before here looks like he's
just playing simple chest Duda is here
comes Queen to d5 this is this is a game
to make Fischer roll over in his grave
and remember the nightmares he had
against Geller in these types of
structures I mean here even f5s a threat
Robert cuz if you pry open the Kings
side then Queen d5 both prepares c6 and
hits the light squares yep I mean this
is just this is this is nasty dude like
a honey badger you you love honey badger
you know I've been waiting day I'm just
gonna do it first because I've been
waiting for a zippity-doo-dah reference
from you but there you go you know you
didn't give me a little James Baskett I
think that's
who wrote that are saying I should say
alright well here here white seems to be
choosing between types of flavors
I mean Queen to d5 that's the move I
would play with the threat of c6
although maybe a twos falling f5 is that
move that's been staring at me but
that's because I can never forget about
mating always got mating on the brain
you know that you can't take a five
because c5 falls I guess you could play
Brooke to b5 if you wanted to both
guards c5 and hit a5 that that's kind of
cool
yeah row 25 is nice actually you're
throwing just said to win that palm for
free I like I like Roxy one dude is
taking his his time here I guess he can
afford it he was up on the clock we see
someone to say syria will crush do today
a hundred percent um well if not right
now he's not yeah looking so far due to
looking sharp and okay plays a Knight
takes e5 i like it's just calculating of
rook c5 he's sorry ninety-five Bishop c5
not taken I was like can I start pushing
my deep on but this is a safer option
you're forcing black to exchange the
Queen's because well the knight on c5 is
hanging you play Queen takes a to I
simply take on c5 and my bishop still
covers the f2 square so don't get any
ideas over there and well if the Queen's
get traded white is up a pawn and it's a
nice pass pawn so Queen before Brooke
before and II for is under direct threat
there as well and just you can't play
Brooke f2d 8 because Bishop c5 works ago
tonight b7 was Hank was an option they
plays 93 so what happens if I scooped up
the e4 pawn I just I just want to take
that there you would ask that what
happens if you just scooped up the pond
now Knight d7 rook d7 rookie 7 is one
option 97 57 what else can I do here how
else can I make the progress
I like well I mean I just like that idea
so Brooke ninety-seven rooked I don't
know you're you're still driving whites
advantage home I feel like this has got
to be a somehow we managed to trade that
week a five pond for that c5 hunter
leader feels like do to let a little bit
of something slip here no I agree with
you but I think he's trading the rooks
off because rook d7 rookie seven you
have to trade for Oaks okay unless it's
a bleep pawn is the D polish is too
strong I guess well now it's gonna
become an e pawn if you take it right so
I think if Ricky seven rookie 7 D tape
c7 Brooke e8 it looks like you're
winning a seven but rook b3 traps the
Black Knight on d3 OMG well there is
night b2 but then I get very rookie semi
Bishop c5 or even rook d7 and then
Knight d6 next move yeah that works I
was Oh actually you could take on e7
because if I take on d3 to take on b7 ah
so much going on here oh yeah that would
be in fact you better be careful if that
happens suddenly white has back ranked
problems over here with this this weird
extended pawn on g3 posing tricky little
problems for the white king yep and okay
that King up one was a nice move a
couple moves back because the knight on
d3 is still in trouble
and you made sure your King wasn't
getting mated and now after Knight B - I
played Bishop c5 and I protect my very
important East 7 pond and well that's
looking like all you need
so here okay well actually now Bishop f6
comes ah Bishop f6 King f1 and a bishop
is a me King up three and at Bishop
takes e7 there was a hit but but it's
the Epona no he gets out just in time
another Bishop leave and one rookie one
if you take on e7 with the rook I trade
rooks and I'm a pawn you take with the
bish 27 your bishops and okay same idea
rook d7
yeah he's gonna force the exchange of
rooks and the point is that the a pawn
is just too strong too fast
- da funk bigger stronger faster nice
and another rook and Bishop restricting
night ending by the way but I suddenly
the young the young polish immediate I
don't even know what to say I mean at
this point but he's he's on the route of
being to being ahead in this match and
making sure everyone knows that he came
to play yeah he came not just to play to
win and you'll MIT you and I Danny had
these conversations earlier and not
earlier today but just earlier this week
we're discussing you know how big of a
favorite was carjacking and you know you
have to consider him a huge favorite but
you you and I both thought that Judah is
this player who's been on the rise
extremely promising and well he's not to
be underestimated and there goes the a
pawn wait a second
if Bishop c5 don't play knight c6 than
f3 turn yeah I lost that in him like
this once but what he did Danny which is
really smart is Knight takes f3 and he
has an H upon that so he's an A and an H
bond and Bishop is good at controlling
the board but it's not that good at
yelling to separate out side passed
pawns and in fact right thank you.thank
it's so it's so not that good that sore
get ready to throw in the towel and I
mean I think I speak for for most the
fans where get your get your Duda emotes
out right I mean I say makes them you
say Duda Danny there you go
I say makes them you say do to make some
make some no that's not happening
I didn't what are you talking about his
name is Duda I know it's your guy no
it's nobody know what you're talking
about I am here for the chess and that's
it and I've been I've been pleased so
far with the performance I have as well
but this use makes them do those I
cannot believe I even just repeated that
you did
speaking of which we're having the dodo
birds right too bad do bad moment of
silence for dodo birds Wow really fast
you did it got real too fast and pretty
excited to have everyone with us nearly
3,000 of you in all seriousness thank
you for being here
namaste to everybody and spending your
Thursday with us here whether you're on
chest comm TV or twitch TV slash chest
so Robert a new opening yet again so
these guys have been mixing it up and
but Duda doesn't seem to be fazed no
matter what Sergey throws Adam so far
yeah and speaking of fazed I'm looking
at sir gays camera and yeah I don't know
if he's moved I don't know he's frozen
or if he just like so focused that is
anyone seen him blink like we may get a
we see if there's no circle you're Duda
Sergei yeah he just looks so intent I
don't know I mean maybe that's his
permanent state of being my aunt and I
know I know you're gonna say that you
know he did this to himself I hope so
you're gonna say that to defend me but
you know exactly what I'm about to
reference right now when it comes to mr.
kuryakin because the lack of movement
the perfect looking position of the
headphones we have our first Princess
Leia reference of the day time for
people to get at me get at me on Twitter
the game is still live so I don't want
to hear that I've left the the show
behind first person who can give me new
photoshop's of a serger Carrie Aachen as
Princess Leia which we did before wins
the one year diamond membership use the
hashtag speed chess and and and get at
us here we've got some of the latest
tweets with the hashtag speed chess and
ooh look at that somebody tweeted the
the Blue Diamond almonds that I've been
eating all day there you go Robert back
to the show all right well I guess I
have to talk about chess now I did
enjoy your Princess Leia reference and
here we see it with the white pieces
cardiac and trying to go with some
sustained pressure and what he's
thinking is that his control over the
king side is more important than dude
his control over the Queen side and what
I mean by control over the Queen side if
you look at the Queen side it looks like
well how can black positive control over
the Queen's eyes locked up black can at
some point play moves like B takes c4
open up the beef or a plate for a5 a4 or
combination of those plans and on the
other side of the board White has the
option play f5 now II five is is hanging
right now so which Queen f3 is a good
move to admit you played Queen g3 or a
similar idea to play f5 but black can
always keep the pawn on f5 actually on
e5 under attack which makes f5 extremely
difficult to play if you've ever played
Bishop d2 is white and rook has the b2
square to access so I do think that sort
of just realizing that the circuit
camera must be frozen yeah okay I didn't
realize it ever since you said the
Willie blink thing I've been staring at
him like shocked just realize he's gotta
be frozen I just realized that and you
were like sir he should quit chess and
enter staring contest I don't I don't
know exactly how to bother him right now
but I'm gonna try to get him he's been
pretty active on skype so sorry keep
commentating buddy while I troubleshoot
this that was hilarious yeah you know I
think from cardiac its perspective his
not only is his camera frozen but his
position is frozen as well because you
play f5 you lose sight of this ePHI pawn
and you may consider playing f5 because
if Knight takes e5 with the Queen not
being on f3 you just push f6 and
sacrifice the pawn so that's something
that is certainly worth consideration if
you are cardiac you know Queen g3 fall
to f5 and f6 ideas so here due to needs
to figure out what to do he can play
rook to be 2 in that way you keep this
night stuck to the e4 square to protect
that bishop on b2 and perhaps black and
then play Brooksie to ensure the
in the second-ranked it looks like a bit
of a long story
I'm also thinking about the move I was
gonna say g6 and he played it and the
reason why g6 is of course an option is
that it protects the f5 square and it
hey I think I'm on in yeah go ahead and
turn off your camera and come back for
everybody okay well I look like um mr.
Sergei Kuryakin who was trying to
troubleshoot his camera right now keep
going we're doing gay now it's mrs. fun
know what that was funny so you know why
he's trying to push through on the
kingside here and the reason why g6 is
possible is because little dark squares
were not under threat with the bishop on
e7 it really covers these vital squares
f6 and d6 now Kuryakin is trying to make
magic happen he would love to make
progress here and he put his bish Bungie
three so that he can play at five and
well he's in time because f5 now I mean
that just opens up the position if
you're black you can play Queen e8
exactly and add to play Queenie it I'm
tempted for white I play Knight f6 check
saying I'm forcing you to capture me and
it also hits the rook on BHO plate ft6 F
takes c6 Knight f6 check I think you in
material forces are capture and the take
back everyone has a double threat of to
forking the king and queen and spying
the rook on b8 so uh a Greek town
population us Sergei may have his camera
frozen but his position is not anymore
so sitting there taking his time min
okay slightly different approach I don't
understand where do we miss we didn't
miss anything I think that was just
winning I think that if six check was
only a million times better
only so you're saying there's a chance
what I miss a chance now there what
black would love to do is put a move
that Queen to a8 here get the Queen you
want a rook f8
you also want to attack the long
diagonal it plays rook c2 hoping to play
Brooke other rook to be two but there's
no check me right if I played let's say
I give black two more moves route B to B
to look G to check okay
uh-1 I didn't have to sacrifice my queen
for the two rooks and so I think that
black is in a very difficult spot here
and I hate that I think that now
Kuryakin is going to win this one I
don't I didn't understand him missing
medicines check felt like a winning move
but okay if he's gonna play this it
still looks good so okay King g7 you
have to do something like this now you
can play e5 without running into Queen
d5 with the check that's one thing
that's nice but okay e-file still play
Queen D for him anyway he's still in
control if you're Sergei but yeah he did
he did miss Knight f6 check but now I
don't see how you deal with the e pawn
and then the potential of the the D pawn
so look looking pretty good right and
all right so Queenie for I mean does
black coming out a move he took on a -
so it's Queenie 626 Ricky six we've got
a Queen trade the rooks company seven
we'll check
maybe uncle material but the position is
far from the class for sure yeah it
seems over honestly we have our first
donation with a message here to read
Robert shredder Roy says the dudes going
to get carjacked get it play on words
Duda in khari Aachen when you when you
have to say get it that's already a
tough spot also another another rook and
Bishop were struck with this - Roxanna
bishop was two ropes and a knight so
every time we've seen this yes pink with
the bishop Bruce to do with a knight so
maybe we should ask about that later I
also want to point out that cardiac and
joke there was an mr. t niece named many
years ago that was avoid carjacking
roads and roads but like Michael Road
rst and that was I was pretty clever I
remember but I feel like the carjacking
has been butchered by Americans for long
enough so we do appreciate the donation
but okay but yeah well circa is still
trying to figure out his webcam while he
also figures out the right way to
outplay the his polish opponent but he
did do so that
brought the match score to level so with
about 35 minutes left here in the
five-minute portion we have a tied match
but I don't know that everybody thought
we'd get as far as these two guys coming
in on paper but but doo de doo to bring
in it and karyakin once again avoiding
the Berlin this is actually something we
should keep in mind for the post match
interviews because he played three a six
in the Spanish in this one so he decides
not to play in the Berlin and Duda
interestingly decides to play in
exchange and I've had experience from
the white side and the black side of
this opening I feel like it's more
fighting than people give it credit for
so give it a living up to his username
polish spider and you know he's trying
to don't worry about it he's trying to
test it it's okay yeah where did I go
it's what I want me you're not here
anymore
that's the thing okay well you me as
long as you can hear me you don't need
to see me it's probably better for
everyone anyway go ahead well let my my
sleazy cars men salesman the facial hair
lead the way yeah you know I'm gonna
just big I'm gonna I'm gonna bist right
now so anyway about the position itself
as we figure out where my camera went it
looks like that you know black is doing
all right in the two bishops your
position is quite solid and v6 is
generally speaking a very important move
because New Castle queenside right away
Knight c5 happens and you have these
double pollens which means that White
has a stable structural advantage the
problem for blacks have you castle on 95
is the advantage that black does have is
having a slight score Bishop whereas
white clearly does not have one you to
give that up to double those pawns in
the first place and so here the b6 move
stops the knife from infiltrating black
can eventually castle whoa I got huge
and will eventually castle the rook will
come to right now just don't worry about
it
I'm not worried I'm just worried for all
the fans I've worried about myself just
you know one make sure that people are
breathing okay they can listen and and
learn and alright so
Judah first the D file first to create
some pressure along that file painting
the bishop but you're nine times are
really doing anything of significance if
the knight was on d4 you can make a move
by Knight takes some six but ninety four
here is met by the move Bishop to I say
e seven note that Bishop d6 cannot be
paid by black next move so let's I
played I move like f3 for a white Bishop
d6 my run into Bishop takes c6 so its
keep an eye on that
additionally black is kind of played
Bishop e7 probably should be e6 and that
way the Brooks can get traded and black
is not to be concerned and I'm trying to
think of this black want to trade both
rooks are just one I think you want to
trade both pair of rooks so that you
enter an endgame potentially with the
two bishops advantage whereas if you
trade one pair Brooke I think the white
rook is more active and I'll see a real
plan for the black rook so so far very
normal position let's see 95 well that's
looking good b3 though b3 maybe Knight
g4 here yeah it's hard to want to keep
distracting surrogate chops because
camera right now everyone while he's
involved in a match but we're doing our
best
right now Robert looks great this is
proof of how good-looking you are even
in closer
High Definition you look just as good
buddy so I appreciate not something I
can say for myself so good for you
h3 though guard chief or here comes up
for me likey oh and beer hall and your
lovely Robert don't worry what a
sweetheart
that's only minor my day okay so they're
all the works are finally gone and we'll
see that the bishop on e6 you can
support the c5 c4 idea promised e5 is
that now white can play Knight d5 the
good thing about not having any rooks
though is that then black cameras on
Bishop 83 if you so choose and say well
my bishop was just gonna sit here and
you can't kick me out
and then black plays c4 after that so
for example Bishop 95 if you want it you
could take on d5 of course but which you
very well may consider because after 95
Bishop d5
and if I'm black and mental I see four
as well white can hereby Knight f4 to
protect this night to come to d5 because
after night at forty throwing the bish
one and six
but either way no matter once this night
guests in d5 I can play Bishop III and
try to follow it up to c4
if white plays Knight d5 and see for
himself then black can played b5
attacking the Queen side pawn so it's
something to keep in mind that just
because that C to pawn may reach the c-4
square it doesn't mean that there's a
problem and I think that Judah is down
being down a minute on the clock could
could be another issue time management
has not been his strong suit I would say
in the first five games of this match
he's been down the clock very frequently
and he plays 95 here trying to liquidate
I think he realized that he's the one in
danger of getting in trouble
and so he's rate pieces
okay now play Knight takes before and
you've no no problems whatsoever because
they're an obstacle I'd be spending
that's for sure a possibility
do you want to play f4 is white by
playing it f4 you kick a night away but
you also create some weak squares you
want a move like Bishop c1 here for
white threatens the trap that Bishop but
the move a for me next but I was gonna
say if you played Bishop c1 is white
then c-4 would have happen for black now
you could play Bishop c1 renewing the
threat of the night as the d3 square to
use for blacks pay for a good move very
useful and okay now Knight takes d4 pawn
takes before a 90 for the bishop just
moves away from you 6 to say d7 I think
that black is the one who should be a
little bit better here
so you can also play the move pawn takes
b3 here because that's a pawn takes be
through Knight takes c6 King yeah ii 7
knight back to before B 2 you can stop
queening so after pawn b3 you should
just take back on be through at the pond
and then the bishop can remove itself to
say d7 black can place c5 after that and
it's pawn on b3 is the the one real
target on the board does this move order
Bishop d7 idea being that now you could
take on b3 also black might consider
playing a3 himself and the reason why 8
3 is a useful move is then you place C 5
and you say that you have a very far
advanced it's not a passed pawn to be
out in front of it but there are some
ideas to try to push that on and push
other pawns and break it free so now c5
for black for sure
looks like a good move and well that
kind of considered Bishop f7 instead of
Bishop d7 because that would have made
it harder for a white to play King up
one with Knight takes two for tactics
available and the a to pawn being a
clear target so it's a knight come into
a five-night a5 here I guess Oh 95
Knight takes b4
what a shot oh that that would be very
nice so Knight things before I guess
it's still good for black yet because
you can take b3 you don't have to take
back oh no with an 83 a b3 1985-86 that
goes for it wow what a shot yep
this looks like the worst is definitely
behind dude
so let's see what can black do did make
any sort of progress it looks like
nothing Knight takes e4 on takes e4 on
me for Bishop d6 check gobs of colored
bishops and what white would be the one
up on their aura yeah one pawn suppose
Bishop e6 so what up no mine that's a
good-looking move it's a real
good-looking move so King deep to here
now I had to pawn b3 pawn b3 night Peter
King c3 and that looks like potential
saving grace for for wiping a knight
back to a5 so pawn b3 palm with your
night b3 check King c3 Knight a5 and the
c4 pawn is still weak you go Knight d5
Bishop takes d5 you could take back on
d5 and try to claim that's Bishop per
person that ending is just absolutely
fine but yeah looks like Kuryakin is on
the better side of this someone equal
look in position I think the night
against the bishop is would be a good
thing for him to have looks like Duda 27
seconds crack in 50 seconds both sides
nearing time trouble you're pretty
amazing doing commentary while I'm
trying to help figure out things for the
show so just want to tell you that tell
you how talented you are mr. Hess the
talented
Bobby has you know I knew my bestest and
well let's look at this now it's a new
ending Bishop versus Knight pawn on b6 +
c5 a very solid setup for black whereas
the policy for cannot has to be
protected by the king and the good news
for y is that the Bishop really does
control many of the squares I I'd be 5
does it now he's a passed pawn I think I
would consider starting with Knight g6
earlier for black just cuz they would
have allowed the night to try to
infiltrate bf4 age 4 yeah ok see forged
moved Bishop away they
to be eight I guess and black better
come back otherwise King c4 comes in ooh
he's gonna allow it
King c4 Knight d7 comes into either a
five or v6 so that's the thing it's a 97
you move your Bishop to f4 probably
might be six Chuck and then the King
okay the problem is even a flat commits
right Knight b6 checking King up this
white skirt this black Bishop will win
them all I didn't see that nights coming
to e5 and then winning the f3 pawn fork
fork town this looks not good for you
then you have three seconds left and the
one second increment will make you know
help him help him defend but not enough
when you're probably losing anyway right
so the knight is ideal in these sort of
situations poking and prodding at
weaknesses on both colors yep here comes
a five but then 94 check would a fork
the king of Bishop again so a king c4
here king c4 infiltrate it's for h4 h4
would have been would have been strong
there and I'm pretty sure if h4g for
black could have just taken with the
night and then h3 that was my idea
yeah alright well doing my best to keep
up with you King c4 here and the bishop
no arm can stay Kingdom three yeah and
with only three seconds on the clock
it's uh it's Rover Red Rover ninety five
game over ninety five seats you check
Knight b3 check c1 queen there it goes
sokar yakun
proving that Hughes in the better side
of what like look like it should've been
a draw with proper play but that's
really the frustrating thing is that you
have a position there where you're like
I know I should be able to hold this I
know I'm not that much worse but then
you also know that you have no time and
you're playing a speed chess match and
car yakin is a monster yeah the guy is
super good super frustrating that's
exactly the kind of endgame were you
imagine if Corey Aachen gets more games
like that it did this is that's the
match that that Duda wants to avoid and
I think he's done a good
avoiding us so far today but that was
that was a vintage Corey Aachen win
right there and due to mixing it up
completely here why I should say
karyakin makes it I would think bishop
about four in the second move and due to
entering very off beat opening so we see
that black has gained space on the Queen
side and normally when you hear the
expression gain space you think that's a
good thing however sometimes you gain
space and it's a terrible thing because
your pawns are overextended and here's
one of those positions where if blacks
King let's say or an H one you already
castle on that you see the pond b5 is a
target the pawn on c5 is very good but
it's more about the b-pawn than anything
and so do a very quick development here
watch out for that b2 pawn Knight h5
would force that Bishop back to c1 so if
you're creating here you might even see
the move Knight to c3 plays Knight h3
saying okay go ahead plane h5 will play
Bishop c1 your knight and h5 is just as
bad if not worse than the fact that my
bishop had to retreat with starting
square and so you know Knight takes d5
would allow probably just pawn takes d5
Bishop be 292 the two pieces and to the
rook and two pawns with two pieces was
not worth it and here though it looks
like Judah is well it's continuing
continuously saying you cannot take my
opponent d5 is clinic fine check so
you're gonna play Bishop e2 you're gonna
castle but the space I gained on the
Queen side that grab is beneficial for
black and you don't really want to play
Bishop b7 at least not yet because the
bishop just stares into a brick wall of
pawns but an idea for buck is to play
it's I'm putting east six it's really
gain more space you don't want to be
left with this pawn on d5 sort of
suffocating your position so it would be
much nicer to be able to play key 6 and
the end especially because white does
not have a policy for it transpose into
a Benoni structure where you don't have
to Dickel with some of the same
consequences thanks to this pawn on d5
what you said
I know I did my best now 90 85 is
actually a threat by the way nightmare
60 because then you were to gain the
third pawn for her with three pawns in a
rook for two miners which is very very
good not conversation it's actually
ample material more than who
so AIC Armenia Eagles it has to be our
exact Manoogian in the in the twitch
chat it always is our attack never get
enough are attacking in our lives so c4
closing up the position Knight h5 played
kicking that Bishop back to c1 and now
it is black play e5 here saying I can
make this move now that your Bishop
there it is your bishops not an F for
hitting my d6 pawn if you take on
passant d takes c6 well I can play
Knight takes c6 ahead right to the d4 or
f4 squares the one thing I will say is
I'm not sure about not positive about
the move where you could have considered
playing Bishop d4 before playing B 5 and
the real benefit of that is just by
putting your Bishop on that square
rather than on g7 you don't you're not
stuck with this lame duck Bishop right
this this is a King's Indian type of
Bishop stuff behind a wall of pawns that
said it's not like white can really make
progress because if you ever play f4
that once again opens up the bishop and
gives it a new life so I think the
decision ultimately was a good one but I
do that leave the bishop there all right
f4 played I mean II takes f/4g takes a
for the night on h5 is awkward so I
guess 97 a knife receipt to eat see 78
pardon me was perhaps not optimal but
Queen h4 here is certainly an option
Queen h4 Bishop h5 take back on h5 yep
there it is and Knight comes to f6 to g4
coming soon to a theater near you Bishop
d4 followed by Knight f6 also classic
[Laughter]
you know also possibility here and
probably a good move
and what else p3 is idea for black and
the reason why I recommend that move at
some point is that
wasn't made up now but it's an option
just because opening the B file could be
useful for that rook to get into the
game this nice swinging into the f3
square next attacking the Queen on h4
ooh give me that pawn that was really
quick calculation by Duda saying I'm
gonna take this pawn off the board
Bishop g5 route Queen g6 Bishop e7 oh it
be - singing I forgot what that oh um
but either way Bishop e7 at the end
traps the work on a fade but I think it
was I mean you can even play queen bee -
Bishop e7 Queen takes a one if that was
the case true I wasn't throwing rook e1
first just to not allow that but okay a
queen g6 a pin and I was negative six
rook g1 is met by Knight takes e4 even
just give me more pawns
yeah like a g4 of course has probably
been a better move there so problems for
Kuryakin he's down down pawn the pawns
on the DL pawns don't look great but you
have a two bishop so this is easy to
take for granted that your opponent can
take pawns on the side of the board
where you think you're gonna be the one
attacking like a BB open F file and
everything that cardiac Kant's to do in
this structure to attack on the King
side you just forget the Duda can sneak
in like a thief in the night just grab a
pawn and now you're all in
now you sack a second pawn just to get
more squares for the ponies yep yeah
Knight comes in to e4 and okay it looks
really nice but the truth is you're
you're down two pawns right am i doing
my math right I mean that's a c5 is
falling
well I even play Queen b6 I mean that's
a lot of and he goes for that's a lot of
pesky here comes f5
yep Bishop g4 and f5 things like that
you're absolutely right in fact I was
thinking that you could even play Queen
c7 to provoke d6
state your Bishop gained the control
that long diagonal
I think Queen b6 is just much smarter
there's no reason to even have to
calculate
giving up that c5 pawn so here Knight g5
what is that threat so what about it
will and threaten this Queen - Queen
takes h5 just straight up but I think
both h6
g4 and even have six and okay yeah
your move Bishop c4 wait outdo me as
always well I'm not I really just don't
want to touch any of my pawns for the
time being I was trying to wait for the
right moment but h6 is also a way to
just call the bluff right because
there's no there's no sac here there's
no Queen takes h5 and then the other
night comes in because black can just
swing the lady over and everything's
guarded so mage six even though it's
kind of the forcing response 295 it
doesn't mean that the knee-jerk response
is the bad response James Coleman and
the chess TV chat just suggested Knight
takes f7 but I don't think that's gonna
be enough for white like just captures
everything yeah yeah knight of seven
rook episode and we're sinking I mean I
would probably just gone for it cuz I
understand that White's position is not
very good so rook takes it taken f7
would have been just like I'm playing
speech as let's just go for a night of
7:00 work if something were up seven
King of seven Queen H budget there it is
but you can't I mean you should not
spend so much time before playing a move
like an actual g4 was an amazing
response and play them amazingly quickly
yeah but I mean how is this anything for
white I don't understand how black is
not just okay so rook f7 rook F 1707
rook up one check and do Kings gate back
Knight f6 check what am I missing a hole
Queen g6 duh yeah yep so you have to
play King out like king he ate here well
no you can do you can sack with the
Queen oh nine f6 you just take with the
Queen that's a lot of pieces for the
lady and in fact due to does it I think
that was brilliant
Queen sac and all the sudden you're like
where'd all my pieces go I have no more
firepower if you're white just rook d8
you can always block on b7 I mean he
wants more than he was to Bob Barker
this he wants to mate white yeah move
the bishop put the other bishop on h3
and problems War II for here I just push
push him baby
efore Queen e3 Bishop f3 check all right
man Rick g8 is not here - I'm trying to
figure out a meet you okay he's going
for the simple plan I first suggested
probably not the best plan but okay no I
read yours Bishop h3 and it's just over
so car er can has to play King G to you
you might have been right by the way
that something like e for
would have been better yeah one of my
run g5 rather than g7 felt like a
more active diagonal and help me push my
epoch so here Bishop F okay mission b6
keep an eye on the d6 pawn so now I get
how do I get this epoch Queen c6 coming
really bond with an e3 maybe within the
Queen e4 I'm not hmm a5 is under attack
so if you take on a5 there's another
pass pawn they have to deal with so
should black play rook f3 here a brave
looking move yes somehow he did not
convert that and this this game should
be over after White was in that mating
yet in the Queen sac yeah Corrie Aachen
has gotten much more counter play than
Duda would have ever liked Oh work f3
Queen age 5 is this bit scary
actually no that doesn't work I was
trying to go rook after Queen h5 Bishop
h3 check and take on h3 but it just
doesn't work because the bishop d4 at
the end won't be sick well you and I
talk about a lot how in this in this
type of format that if if you don't get
something really strong for the pieces
right away the time pressure almost
always favors the Queen it's just harder
to coordinate everybody under time
pressure than it is to play with one
powerful piece so I'm getting nervous as
I see do this clock at under 20 seconds
here yep
I'm with you I think rook g5 was a
decent alternative to Bishop g5 there
but okay this still looks yep Pleasant
how do you get over the checks now Queen
e8 can't seven Queenie for it there's a
crack and also playing for a win but
that might be playing for a loss I'm not
sure yeah rook g6 Oh would you okay he's
just repeating by Leo you can you could
run the King if he wants to go for the
win now now is the time I was gonna say
that's how you play for a win sure about
five Queen d5 here 25 pin the Brooke and
here comes a 7
unbelievable get those penny boats out
cuz that's gonna decide the game here Oh
even stronger Queen b7 can't capture
each - H - okay mister f3 is actually
nice more the h2 was Oh Oh nobody wins -
pawn
so why Nico eh - I think he just missed
it a 7 that's oh this game is this game
was nasty and honestly due to made the
right place AK there's no way I don't
know if he's even losing rook takes ok
goes back there I thought you didn't say
yeah but again it's just it's hard to
coordinate under time pressure so I'm
sure I'm sure black was winning in
several places in this game that the
Queen sac was good but I'm not gonna be
surprised when white wins this game at
this point
yep so the four pawns over there b4 b5
are there any meeting ideas for ah can
you be sick Bishop e3 checking over
there c5 yeah this is just way too many
pawns for white you couldn't capture
because of Queen e6
I mean a 7 no yeah this is just too much
and he loses on time no surprise and
that's all that's a heartbreaker for the
for the Polish underdog here because
that was a game black should've won and
the Queen sac was good but I think he
got passive and nervous moves like
Bishop g7 and rook f7 rather than going
for something more aggressive right away
but ok easier for us to say than for
then for Duda to do to do Duda but doot
da ba dee da ba die i'm blue so he loses
him we move on yeah that's that's that's
heartbreaking for him because now he's
had two games against the ultra talented
cariann and we'll see if he's able to
you know play or at least score better
in the quicker portions because right
now in the 5-minute this might be our
last 5-minute game and probably a pretty
good chance well I mean it depends on
how long it goes if it's a if it's a
long
long Berlin depends on the type of
Berlin we're into the c5 early c5 by
karyakin stopping Knight d4 clearly and
the d5 square
well the nice and one we're at c3 so
normally when you don't want to play c5
is black in it Berlin because Knight
jumps to d5 followed by c4 here at least
black has moved to game so now 95 okay
say throws in this work do and check
first which I like that way the King
can't go to see McCain really wants to
be on c8 so actually this might've been
a blunder by karyakin because Bishop d7
is met by East six and pawn takes east
six there's night g6
and that actually wins the game because
tonight oh and no it doesn't I thought I
would be laying your Bishop but you have
96 feet so never mind take it back let's
put e6000 this feels like the kind of
Berlin that can run quickly off the
rails for black though I like these East
six aggressive lines okay cardiac and
calmly plays Bishop d6 and doesn't care
about his LightSquared Bishop diamond
members Sega morph all the members in
the chest TV twitchtv chess as well we
do read the chat this is our best
situation right now given some technical
issues we're dealing with so if you want
your chat to be read have something
productive and nice to say let's move on
[Music]
what's gonna happen in this Berlin if we
trade the LightSquared Bishop for the
knight on it for let's see so on d7 she
takes that for if you eventually take on
b7 with your king they'll be able to
take on that for my Bishop because the
Bishop d6 will be pins that's the good
news the bad news haven't figured that
out yet it's 97 to hit kick this fork
away from d5
then Brooke ooh I like that actually
so now my rook h5 just developed now the
other rook could come to d1 to h6 pawn
is the target bishops come c3 taking
that rook from it's h8 square and that's
the me actually
if I get another move Bishop c3 wins at
least upon because if you put your work
on h7 there's always Nate g5 tactics so
f6 played by Corey akan but that also
weakens some of the other squares so
plays rook d1 threatening Bishop takes
f4 if you move your king to e6 is he
just did ya do I would think about no
but this is the kind of that reckoning a
trap than h5 something I don't think so
I feel like this is the kind of session
where all of blacks weak pawns were
really gonna be the thing that tells the
story here yeah I mean here comes rook
e1 check there's also this knight on f3
I don't think it's found its final home
yet ooh but you're right okay the
immediate threat of Team g6 is that
forced Knight age 4 looks like it does
if Knight to g6 there's yeah well I want
to play Brooke f5 but probably can't
afford a sack on h4 right now Knight a5
is option for white as well right
because 905 for the trade rook gains
access back to the d5 square and if you
play like Knight f5 King g6 I just take
on e7 with Chuck hitting you work on XI
as well I just you know black is of a
pawn and the pod starting to look a
little bit better you know they're ugly
they're double CC pawns they left pawns
isolated double F pawns
I said h1 but if I can trade those
nights off the board or if Black gets
another moon phase for g5 then all of a
sudden you know whites and quite deal of
troubles he doesn't indeed from the five
costly Richy six to protect this yeah
again this is just so having gone back
to his Berlin I guess Kuryakin is
feeling better about his chances now
than our theories of why he was avoiding
the Berlin after that brilliant age pawn
game that due to had earlier I feel like
it's weird cuz I don't feel like Duda
has been worse than car Aachen but he's
just down to games yeah he missed
opportunity right that last game he was
certainly
the first game with black he was should
have been winning with d5 and said he
ended up losing that end game so there
been moments really where but also to
carry Atkins credit the game at Judah
won the second game overall where crack
and his blunder of Bishop and then threw
away the game so it's uh it's been
definitely I would say slightly in
kuryakin's favor but I'd agree that the
score does not tell the full tale
because it feels like Duda has been
hanging in there toe-to-toe and your
fortunes down but again I guess that's
what they would say right scoreboard you
can hang in there all you want right
scoreboard so and now that he's down
upon in this weird-lookin Berlin in a
minute on the clock you feel like Sergei
is in good shape again yep and the good
thing for Duda is you can't take on g2
Kuryakin can't because rook takes f6
check shuts off at the other nation in
those ropes so the rook on g6 is very
much stuck and they work on g8 would
love to go to EA to trade one pair of
Brooks off but you can't do that because
the f6 pawn is hanging at the end of
that and that but by the same token
white is also frozen right this rook is
about you know a monkey's uncle away
from getting trapped if the wife the
black King can come to g6 some health
you know and my cousin h4 here h4 and h5
to try to remove the rook and take f6
well there you go
I guess one idea is for just meet it
with h5 myself with the point being and
then I take on g2 and I go right back to
f5 okay Robin then you bring that Jeep
to row back to g6 knee of the age six
not only that I wonder if I can consider
moving the g8 rook so that if he took up
six I could move my king to g8 I want to
keep the pressure with my Brooks okay
we're not gonna have this line on the
board anyway this is better for what I
mean you know he's 1 upon so he's white
his up miss or white is even on material
but the pawn structure favors white so I
think Jude has entered a fair blending
yeah he worked he worked it he got out
of that some help
really weird not only has white won back
the pawn it seems like he hasn't lost
any of the pressure he had if white gets
mousse-like g4 and h5 all the pawns on
light squares trapping black pawns on
dark squares is gonna it's gonna really
be good for the bishop battle later on
h5 right now I mean h5 rook up chief for
huh yeah I've trapped your pawns on dark
squares my bishop better than your
bishop I I like where it's headed for
Duda this could be a huge win and I get
the feeling we're getting from one of
those really long matches Robert where
they're gonna finish this game somehow
just under the remaining four and a half
minutes in the five-minute portion and
we're gonna get a whole nother 5-minute
game yeah and I wanted to give a shout
out to gob gob body saying slightly
worse endgame Carrie Atkins element it's
so true
and while we're doing that I'll give a
shout-out to Max Lee neck who I I think
must have polish roots maybe he even
lives in Poland he's saying he donated a
gifted he gifted a sub right there to
one of our long-term fans and said he's
doing it as long as people root for Duda
so he's a dude a fan there yeah and I'm
a fan of give this position right now
because just look it looks good and if
I'm Duda how do I turn in an advantage
into a win at what point do I consider
playing the move F Ford and then
triangle g5 too soon I would say because
rg8 hits the g4 pawn but Bishop e1 is so
nice do peptidase-4 oh I love it I love
it so much
you can't play Bishop e5 cuz yep
pin emo yeah card I can place this move
specifically to deal with Bishop before
everyone so the brook have four can
defend so Bishop h4 rook F for Bishop
takes f6 rook a5 Bishop takes h8 Oh
dirty girl but your business trapped on
if I can if I can trap it somehow well
you threw your rook and then I go b3 and
my bishop has the entire length of
diagonal you might even be able just go
to e5 yeah no I agree
here he goes he agrees
here comes Bishop f6 and that Brook is
like sort of trapped on f4 as well so
after rook f5 bishop h8 rook at four I
go b3 in my bishop
I love his calculation to see that line
he doesn't go for Bishop e5 but b3 is
better anyway cuz it guards c4 and
whether he chooses the e5 or the a1
square he's managed to sneak in there
grab f6 and unless time becomes an issue
here dude is about to bring the match
one game closer so oh and he's tf2 is a
very nice move because now here he can
play Bishop e5 take take rook d4 kingi 2
and there's no check in the second ring
oh my gosh just such good technique
they're saying no to counter play
instructor for everyone at home even if
you can win pawns like this don't allow
your opponent to get active counter play
especially in O'Rourke ending this is
just this is as good of a game as we've
seen from Duda from start to finish in
the match so far you would agree yeah
and I feel like I kind of want to call
him sub-zero because this looks like a
flawless victory at the time that's
right aw dude morale I know that
reference like little one saw coming
yep I know I mean seriously he's he's
been down the clock in this game but
really nicely up there it goes work back
start pushing your own pawns King III
can always be played
so Brooke be too keen III just keep
everything under control
also roof d7 check might now just be
winning because you become OTE 3 I don't
know why he didn't do that people loving
your mortal kombat reference in the
chest TV chat diamond members screaming
finish him well that's what I'm looking
for here we go h6 comes for k2h I think
we're gonna get one more game if this
game ends in the next few seconds we're
gonna get one more game in this time
control Judah has to be very careful not
to lose on time he's on a four point
nine second row takes d5 Brooks Brooks
c7 check coming just do it check check
don't flag wait you're done oh oh my
gosh I don't know one point six seconds
left
age six do it we had one second left
when he made that move okay he got this
barely yeah no that was a lot closer
than it should have been but I think it
came in under the under the under the
clock they get one more five-minute game
which means all the fans here you get
you get basically ten minutes extra of
chess in this match because the way of
the rules is if the game starts before
the time runs out the game continues and
and it counts toward the total score so
that was that was bonkers yeah and I'm
not sure who that's good for because I
would assume that karyakin who has a
lead right now
is not too displeased to play a lot of
long game you know dude has been really
hanging in there every single one and
you know hanging in there's a terrible
phrase because it makes sound like oh
he's so much worse well it's just hard
though because car ducking is such a
heavy favor on paper and he was leading
the match too but you know I think it's
a fair thing to say there's nothing
wrong with hanging in there if you could
hang in there to the end anything can
happen
yeah no I better be think he's really
hanging in there he's going punch for
punch you know his username is fighter
Manny
they've been fighting and that ended
Sergey has come back and me Sergey was
down two and a half one and a half yup
he wants games in a row and this so my
client is saying to me that this might
be the lowest number of draws in the
five-minute portion I think he's only
been one so far
usually we get more draws in the longer
time is that only in one draw in the
five-minute he says it's likely a record
or tied for the fewest of draws but
he'll uh he'll Chuck on that cuz because
that's what he likes to do is he pets
his cat at his desk like dr. evil checks
on stats yep and I just gotta give my
client a shout out because I ran into
him yesterday at the US Open and yes I'm
probably not at his desk thanks for
letting me know that you got yourself
some tickets to the US open mic you
weren't invited anyway Danny I know that
but people people frustrated by the
graph and of course we want to have
these players faces on cameras we're
deal with some tactical difficulties
thanks for hanging in there all 3500 of
you but you know you got to admit the
graph going back and forth in a match
you
thought would have these two heads
headed the opposite direction at the
very least it reminds you to use the
emotes they're they're kind of like
dancing they're sort of doing the tango
those little heads on the graph there so
you say heading in the direction I'm
just gonna point out that you did
something clever I gotta give you props
where props we do every once in a while
all right well like you said I don't
know who this favors either from a
momentum perspective it kind of favors
the Polish fighter given that he he just
won a game in this time control and and
you know maybe finding his stride a
little bit but and given that he is
facing a stronger player who's already
kind of proven himself in this format
this is dude his first time ever
competing in the SEC I feel like as the
time patrols get faster cardiac ins his
strengths get get better but you know I
don't know maybe you know after
afterwards we'll fight we'll see if Duda
has something to say about that so and
this game I already like the way it's
going for black at least as far as some
counter play goes did oh I thought for a
second I thought he gets blundered okay
but no black seems okay well f6 is
actually very you see I move because it
stops the bishop company 5 to protect
the pawn on c3 and now give us a king
access you up to the f7 square and
there's no real attack for white I mean
how do you make progress G for your f3
pawn is obviously just going to fall and
even if your f3 pawn wasn't falling g4s
and threaten anything because g5 score
is so so controlled and so I would
consider two options here to offens here
for for black I would consider one idea
is trying to play b3 myself
acknowledging that after our C takes B 3
C takes B 3 a3 the entire position is
shut down between side another idea
which he's going for which is much
stronger is playing rook b8 rook d7 big
one just gets me so excited about some
sort of mate on the a file yeah Queen a
for ideas and you know he just plays
like this well we just put everything on
the B file eventually play a 4/4 black
say I'm gonna go against your weakness
unbeatable yep and it's very clear that
black is better now be careful before
you play my rook 8
to be 8 because Bishop takes each six
does look a little bit troublesome that
said after Bishop h6 gh6 Queen h6 the
rook can always swing right back to g8
and shelter that king also black let's
play e5 at some point that deserves
mentioning as well because II five wins
the d6 pawn yeah well especially if you
can do it safely you don't even need to
get d6 for it to be a good idea but you
can backup your Bishop to e6 remove any
pressure and then continue with your
plan like you're saying on the V file
again this feels like Duda is in control
and and we'll see if that continues into
the faster portions Robert but other
than those early games I actually really
like the way he's managed his time he's
played quickly when he's known what to
do and now it's a critical moment you
know he's he's 40 seconds in he really
wants to make sure he develops the
attack right and we talked about his
coaches the difference between taking
time and time management right managing
your time is about you know not wasting
it and then knowing when to use it and
it feels like he's he's doing a good job
of that here at the end of the five
minute portion yeah absolutely
and I mean what's white doing in this
game kind of going back and forth like a
green engine so why is that King on g8
like what are you volunteering okays
running to h7 say I'm gonna meet Queen
she through f7 that's actually yeah well
he's just gonna sit and he's gonna
continue to do your idea of it fancy
where's the counter play for white yeah
yeah it's interesting that he didn't
move his rook first before doing this I
guess he was just concerned and trying
to eliminate ideas it takes h6 o c3 open
up that bishop to the a2 square Oh
oh yeah it's happening
take on b4 just open up everything get
dirty on the a5 I mean this is
something's gonna happen over here
opposite colored bishop attacks gone
wild how does this work outs pawn before
Bishop before I won't you know what I
want to do I want to take on a - King
takes then take on be 400 doesn't work
the issue is the Queen's gonna come to
e4 at some point and eliminate my mating
ideas along with it but if black can
just bust open the a file with force in
fact so much so that Carl can wants it
off
bored I think Bishop it takes a to was a
threat and also Queen takes C - of
course I totally missed that move right
like with you know you take the C to
pawn and then all of a sudden blacks
senior White's King feels much less safe
now you're up in exchange for how many
pawns two pawns
so that's actually a pretty level
materialistically but if we look at the
board itself you know why isn't it quite
a passive setup blacks you go after this
h5 pawn either by playing efore and just
turn it to swing over and take it or by
playing Queen f7 and going after it
slowly but yeah it's the bishops not
this was a great defensive yeah honestly
that's one of things that you know so we
got really excited about it or at least
I did as the chat noticed um the the
thing is that - Sergei what makes him so
good is just recognizing those practical
opportunities right Robert I mean he
just seriously just transitioned into a
situation where the exchange is super
irritating to deal with this Bishop is
locked in on the dark squares d6 managed
to get you know held through that whole
process somehow and and why does White
is in decent shape given the situation
right yeah that's that's what he does
best that's it that's how Sergei earned
his nickname is the Minister of Defense
I would probably play four things before
here and do it immediately and it does
yeah he does it and now at the very
least you could win d6 and even if it
has for a peaceful result that's
probably a way for black to avoid losing
honestly by taking him before
well what and white needs to watch out
pawn takes e4 rook c4 pawn takes if I
book c1 check and that wins for black so
actually black is the one I really like
blacks position I don't see peace at all
because d6 is hanging c4 is hanging and
blacks King is much safer than white so
oh I think you know he looks he won
because he was worried about Pawnee for
Brooks he fort as mentioned now you can
consider like III saying you know what
I'll do something of a file later who I
playing III I'm gonna play f4 next and
I'm gonna open up that diagonal that b1
h7 diagonal and your King's not safe I
have a really nice protected past on
that you're gonna have to worry about
for the rest of the game so there it is
ya know that was a really strong move I
agree and and f4 doesn't work because
you want
f-for for white to stop black right but
then immediately there's things like
rook-a for and queenie for exactly cells
back at for for black now f for pot
we're super strong f floor probably
forces chief for right just just just to
may make him stay off of that diagonal i
think chief or is needed
oh he takes it but here comes Queen of
five you don't look now
I love blacks position don't look now
I'm looking I know you told me not
saying I don't look don't look it I
don't when was you thinking about don't
even think about the a final yep this is
uh this is trouble in fact did Sergei
just I mean how was G for not to move
there I figured he had to go for
something like this this is oh my gosh
he's gonna run the King to be three rook
a for King be three Queen a five I'm
threatening Brooke before but that's not
that is that how big of a threat is that
because a quick Queen rook a for King be
three clean up Queen takes III and now
all of a sudden why Saran India okay but
just for a practical perspective here I
mean okay Brooke a for King b3 I'll just
back the rook up to a seven and your
king on b3 that's just okay I mean these
you know grandmasters these days don't
get scared of things they play more like
computers than than any generation
before them because engines have taught
us we gotta be gotta be strong
calculators but I don't know this
from a human human being perspective it
looks like white is gonna be a lot of
danger yeah this is Queen at for Brooks
III good defensive resourcefulness by
Kuryakin so here he can play King b3 and
then I did will backup Brigade howdy
sick don't play c5 rook Queen if what
would have been made oh but if not here
Queen d6 rookie a check and I think
everything is traded well I know can I
start thinking about trading queens for
white I can think about playing rook e8
take take Queen g6 big doesn't quite
almost no but ya know it's a nice idea
rook b8 king c3 he's probably gonna play
Queen f6 check forcing forcing rookie 5
yet cuz any other King move would have
either dropped b2 or d6 with check
oh nice f4 is how many what's up to
pause I was just one Wow
okay well the cardiac can should
definitely be bringing this game and
look and do this clock once again six
point four seconds left and okay so now
I'm Ricky eight well rookie hey there
might be some issue with Queen f6 King
c2 now Queen up five checks of King c2
queen of five whoa g5 what is that it's
a that's a needed move to play we only
have two seconds and I think we're about
to see one of those games or cardiac and
swindled it again if that's what we can
call it when he defends and then somehow
was winning under time pressure it's
over trade Queen f7 check at the ladies
off at c6 boom you know that wins Queen
d7 check can't hurt either but yeah
calculating it if Queen f7 everything
gets traded c6 takes king c5 King e8
King takes c6 King to d8 yeah here it is
King struck very nice move or king c5
and just play King takes c6 first and
then you clean with check and it's over
yep wow wow wow
we officially have reached the end of
the five minute or Shin no no no no no
abort the game abort abort abort mission
oh man okay we're gonna let them know be
a zoom that that's it
yeah dude it and the take a break
Sergei is um we're gonna try to work
with Sergei to get his camera right all
of you should just stay tuned and don't
go anywhere we will be back in just a
moment for the 300 portion
in a super close match and we are we are
back
Robert Hess with me and still muted
though he needs to unmute himself but he
is back he is with me
I've been busy chatting with everybody
and twitch so I you know I'm trying to
you know what that's what we pay you for
is keep the fans happy we're just happy
you're still accepting cheez-its as
payment what what are we gonna say about
the the the match so far right we've got
we've got something that the stats
apparently predicted as far as a roughly
five to three score in favor of the
Minister of Defence that being surrogate
car Aachen but it still feels like to
you and I that due to has not only held
his own but has shown that this isn't
gonna be one that Sergei is gonna run
away with at least not to this point
yeah absolutely not I mean it's been a
very close match in terms of gameplay
the results show a two-game lead for
karyakin but it's really been anyone's
match thus far crack in finding the
right plans at opportune moments in the
first game of the match it was in really
hot water and he somehow survived not
only did Tsubaki end up winning that
game and we've seen a very common theme
rook and Bishop for Koryak adverse rook
and Knight before Duda I don't know if
that's been intentional we know that
Bobby Fischer used to love pointing at
pieces and just saying you know this
piece is gonna be a good 30 moves from
now and I want to keep that piece versus
my opponents future bad piece so well
it's an interesting thing right because
it's not something you'd always think
about in terms of chess you want to
think just objectively it varies every
game whether it's a rook and Bishop or
rook and Knight being better but I do
think there's something to the fact that
players have a style or they just tend
to prefer the coordination of particular
pieces working together right we all
know that the bishop pair tends to be an
advantage especially the early you can
get it because it's harder to keep a
position close than it is to let it
become open but it's interesting to see
that as we head into the end games Karak
intends to have peace peace duo's and
coordination x' that repeat themselves
so okay we're going to start the
three-minute portion pretty much right
now
as soon as both players are log
and ready which looks like they are we
did everything we could here to
completely fix the check and we've come
as far as we can at this point it's time
for the show to go on right now the
players will not be on camera due to the
due to the issues that they're
experiencing on their end but but here
we go here we go and we're underway oh
well there we go finally underway
finally underway just took a second and
we see another Spanish oh and back to
the Berlin it's gonna be Berlin all day
I feel at this point karaoke and despite
being in trouble the first game they had
has has been doing just fine his black
since then yeah no I mean Kuryakin has
been he's also very fast and that's
gonna be important and I think by
creating a position where he's not
struggling so mightily as you might in
some and things like that it allows him
to continue playing at the pace that he
feels comfortable and Duda actually is
the one who has been jetting out to the
early time and binge okay a couple
seconds but I say don't dismiss that
several seconds in the opening can be
really essential later on in the game
and due to interestingly enough was
thinking now I moved ten and it's a
pretty common position place but it's
because if seems like he's tried a
couple different approaches to this
point right and maybe he's just you know
this is a this is like really old-school
Berlin right
white white bringing the bishop to be to
where some of the more modern tries have
have seen the bishop go to the h2 c7
diagonal with ideas of e6 I feel like
this is this is like calm ski Berlin for
white yeah I mean you know back when
they thought the Berlin was just a way
to get be a slightly worse as black this
was how white played because it feels
like all right white just has a better
structure a four-on-three on the Kings
side and black has to spend all this
time coordinating but I think as the
knowledge of this structures evolved we
know that black has the bishop pair this
LightSquared Bishop on this diagonal is
a really tough nut to crack and
eventually black gets almost just as
good a chances sometimes with these four
on three despite them being doubled so
it's just
the way the the approach to this
position has evolved and this in this
line white pretty much has to move that
I don't have three and try for things
like f4 right yeah no it means all fee
Matic at this point I guess the real
thing that's keeping waste attention is
did I play c4 because and there it goes
but these are moves that you really
shouldn't be spending 20 seconds on in
three minute game I agree it shows that
young Christoph may be having a little
more trouble remembering his prep or the
positions he prefers in these lines but
but okay
I mean not the end of the world just yet
I agree with you though that it's a it's
a bad sign as we've transitioned to the
faster time control that young Christoph
is already this much now on the clock
yeah for sure the night coming here to
what either e 2 and F 4 or H 5 and F 4
yeah and g 5 okay of course you play g 5
to stop night at 4 on the flip side you
do give access the F 6 squared but what
is the known f 6 do it can reroute us
off to d5 but it's on the central square
instead he plays G 4 it can bring us
King up in the near future it's a g2 g3
play for ID is a pawn to h4 upon the f4
I tend to always feel like g4 so
double-edged if Black has kept the light
square bishop just because the potential
weaknesses with a screen g4 black could
ever get h5 though I guess what you
would say is the night on h5 here pretty
much means that that's not happening in
this structure yeah okay h5 shuts down
that side of the board and so he plays
that for himself and they were a night
of for cook and we H and G versus H
two-on-one majority black does not have
the same kind of majority because the
pawns are double on the Queen side yep
that said look at the white king it's a
bit exposed so right on what you got
swinging over up to g8 but the same on
h5
that Bishop on e7 can jump over to h4 or
to g5 yep - it's night and so it's not
like blacks position is particularly bad
but what I'm not liking and I'm gonna
say this a lot I feel like is look at
the clock situation no I was good about
to say so the only thing you don't like
so far about whites position has been
his time management given the way he's
played this Berlin right yep and watch
out for 96 check by the way oh
96 pawn takes pawn takes Bishop d6 my
knight Knight takes east wait a second
96 maybe even more powerful now well if
you get rid of the bishop on e6 okay why
not Knight d5 though why take on on e6
if you can go to d5 and undermine the
dark square Bishop then suddenly c5
becomes weak right so I say Knight d6 oh
I'm sorry I misunderstood you okay yeah
I was looking for Knight d6 check
honestly but now it's I guess the rook
on e1 is probably needs to take some
time to get the King off the chief oh no
don't don't play king of two I think as
a bishop h4 but maybe maybe we have to
get away with King age too you could
even get away with King up to Bishop h4
King F 3 cos c5 would hang with check as
well that would have been interesting
you not the worst thing in the world and
he just puts his enough sex why not
taking up space rook d7 can come in I
guess so but combined with the issues on
the clock and the way that it feels like
the advantages they are there there and
now we're simplifying again it's just
car Aachen you know playing playing the
moves he needs to as who made the
comment earlier in the twitch chat that
cariocans slightly worsen and ending
right in his comfort zone
yep that was one of the been seriously
if those who didn't follow the 2016
World Championship matching its Magnus
Carlsen car Aachen is he's just really
accurate and really good at at at
playing positions where he's a little
bit worse plus I think emotionally too
he just has the nerves of nerves of
steel right Corey Aachen doesn't beat
himself in those situations no that's
right it sure he his great nerves and
those type of scenarios I think it's a
little overblown year how you know he is
very good defender I don't think he's
always a very good defender and we saw
that in the sink filled cup in
particular he collapsed in some certain
and some difficult positions but you
know obviously throughout his career
he's proven himself very mighty player
and he usually is great preparation as
well so it's not like he's always in the
back foot defending but when he is
unfortunately for him struggling in a
position he does tend to find some
really great ideas yeah and this game
he'll need to find some yeah I was gonna
say do to do to not again the main thing
is time here because Duda is doing
everything you should do in this type of
position
and if cauri aachen falls asleep or it
makes even a single trade of rooks the
cheap on is is the only passer on the
board
yep night at four can come at any moment
because there it is and it should write
it guards h3 everyone and hits East six
okay or g5 just push it push him baby
push him baby here we go yes or in the
house push a baby here we go and don't
stop seeing again enough right just
don't stop till you get enough no
seriously
given the time ending this this is gonna
be one of those either cariocans
swindles him under time pressure or he
goes down because this should be waiting
for what well what's going on I mean
White's losing all the queenside pawns I
don't need those Queen side pawns
you know you think nineteen to be three
take it I don't wanna give me six Oh 93
he's super good no but he's got rook up
seven yeah Brooke f7 is very well
whether it happens on the F file or the
G spot I'm getting a good night what if
I just take on f7 G takes and play rook
f8 and then like Jake's takes rook a
fake king of six and you're gonna sack
your rook and get a queen that's what
you're saying I'm trying to do that but
I don't know if works so wait rook f7 g
f7 mage nineteen's b3 yeah well this is
one of those funny moments who
calculates better with no time on the
clock we're about to find out because
we're gonna under 10 96 96 first no he
does any place I think that was a huge
mistake wasn't it
I thinks he thinks no I think you should
have played Knight takes c6 okay but
he's gonna taking advantage of the rook
not being able to leave the back ranked
everyone brilliant now he can get a
queen and that a pawn never fell
delicioso take it 7 d 8 even nicer and
black is overwhelmed
yeah 97 East 6 game of 1976 honestly we
had questions who would handle our first
true time scramble where the position
isn't clear yet better and it looks like
Duda is uh is gonna hold his own in
these scenarios because he actually just
took down karaoke
in a position that wasn't clear with
very little time on the clock really
nice play there that was really
something and that you know they both
had a bit of a break because of the
technical difficulties and now it looks
like Duda came back with a fresh head on
his shoulders yeah because that was
really a fight and Liam says gets get
some you bought it he gets moved bought
it just for doing the twitch thing so
we're sorry about that but don't go too
crazy apparently um all right well this
is this is exciting I'm glad to see that
again the man who's supposed to be the
heavy underdog you know what he's doing
he's making those heads bounce those
heads are going back and forth they are
heading in similar directions right now
ships in the night oh you stop no you
stop it no you stop it
you stop it was upon you five hanging to
the back half what does the analysis
board say wasn't instead of B six you're
saying yeah what was happening there
night C I mean is it like a sack 95
Bishop before takes a three takes as
white getting some sort of pressure or
something I I tend to agree with you
that this looks like it was a pawn even
if white has minimal compensation it I
feel like there's been two games where
Duda like didn't take the obvious
approach and maybe that's a little bit
too much respect for his opponent I know
you said that okay that's probably not
true he's a very strong player but but I
agreed that that actually seemed like a
blunder out of the opening from Sergei
yeah but this also looks okay for black
it's like what's the opening a caro-kann
where y is double pawn
yo that's sort of the vibe of this
position you push h4 h5 which tends to
be good but this pawn on c3 is on e5 and
they go ignore and and it's a big
difference everyone because with the
pawn on e5 you have this sort of grip
pawn structure where both these pawns
hold back f7 and g7 which gives white
these long-term advantages in the
endgame hashtag Krum big lake of 2004
world championship check out the game
but again chess games calm chrome nickel
eco check it out I should probably be
recommending something on chess calm but
the chess player takes over me chess
games is easier to
games it's the truth yeah for sure so
and you also you're me you're on fire
with your recommendations day with
Geller Fischer you know I want the
people to learn you know it seriously
this is this is a better version for
black than you normally see there
because of whites lack of structural
binding on the kingside yeah and the
good news is what for wipe the I mean
the only good news I can think of here
is that the White King is very safe
nothing the King is ever in an
engagement for having the four pawns
their young extra shelter but yeah I
mean I didn't know white is doing
perfectly fine here I like whites in
many grave danger
well actually wait a second like yf5
it was kind of yeah Dib Duda again miss
a tactical shot he's giving his opponent
you know the benefit of the doubt but f5
would have been really scary here right
yeah I agree with a rook on h1 for sure
maybe it's not as strong as we think if
the bishop goes to d3 what the follow-up
is I don't know what it was because 95
the broken d7 was hanging you're right
yes so I so white was okay but okay 98
you got a guard east six that makes
sense
by the way Danny it's with the white
pieces karyakin is four and a half out
of five and Duda is four and one he's
four and a half out of five and we
haven't noticed that yet that must have
come from mr. Klein no it came from
smarter chess whoa
no kidding smarter chess hashtag
competition with stat boy that's why you
should be looking up stats not at the US
Open Mic hey Oh Danny this is reminding
me of some Fischer right now look at
that be five square look at that see
Foursquare oh I love it
positional chess at its best no I that
King could be on you know in an endgame
read queens bring that King in that'd be
excellent
um is it's gonna be hard to find avenues
in if you could put the King on b5
that's one thing but okay why could play
Queen e4 right okay he wants to keep the
Queen's on the board I'm wondering who
who does it favor with the ladies off
here teach us something Bobby I think
black is perfectly
ten training off the Queens because
there's a three on four majority well
its minority for what it's called from a
minority perspective because in its
actually the last pons can't move they
can't mobilize in any way whereas white
can start poking yeah why you talking
about poking I was highlighting a night
journey that just might end with Frodo
throwing the ring and mount Mount Doom
there right this is like this is oh this
is a journey worth taking the night's
gonna come to be five and we're gonna
get mate somewhere on the black King
here I feel it I'm calling it so your
town crackin - don't stop believin in
some of these lights core weaknesses
dough yum - don't stop believin I'm
telling you you know mr. Frodo
we can't give up now you say journey I
gotta think
don't you know immediately it just has
to happen but I mean this is just so
unpleasant for black about King day 796
check would be funny so that's not gonna
happen
but it's just nice to show ya that would
be that would be a penny mote waiting to
happen every 196 check Queen a seven
he's poking he's prodding I don't even
know what the follow-up is but the lady
looks good over there
maybe she flips to a che no she did I
was gonna say that I didn't know what
the follow-up was for a good reason
because there was nothing there play 93
Sergei do the logical thing I guess he's
like well I could put my 9 and a 3 and B
5 but then what okay the issue really is
that this work on d5 is so solid here
and prevents the mating attack that I
predicted from happening but okay Oh
something has happened okay Knight takes
85 is also on the radar watch out for 90
X 85 and Queen takes e5 if possible bad
that's very interesting I mean the
knight first of the three pawns the
white king of saving his are pushing
your pawns for it mhm
I actually kind of like that he's
probably calculating it he's got a
minute to do so okay doesn't go for it
probably the smarter decision now that
the rook is gone as I said eventually we
would have this diagonal be an issue but
Carl can doing what he does best having
an advantage on the clock poking it
weaknesses on both sides of the board
three no Queen d3 comings take over the
D file well even this right make make
due to have shovel bring the knight
around eventually I've been calling for
it all day oh but now now blackness is
like
five there it goes @ v e4 this is
actually a problem you want to by way of
heat
what did he do that no he's gonna bring
the 94 but in Queen g6 makes Knight to
c4 right okay but now Queen e8 he missed
Queen he ate Ally buddy son it's not
over yet gotta be over Queens coming to
d7 coming to c6
Queenie okay Queenie if I was
hanging but he's just gone 496 yeah this
is going for the dead the Queen's coming
to c8
and with no time on the clock that's how
the west was won Wow
all right well cardiac imbalances back
we've seen both players have quality
games here in the three minute portion
Robert your thoughts right now with a
two-game lead for the for the Russian
that was a very important win for
Kuryakin a very nice technique there and
he just was had a slight advantage he
kept it growing kept it growing kept
pieces on the board made do to continue
to think and as Ben mentioned plenty of
times dude as time management has been
an issue and to be fair that was the
tough position but he just can't be
spending the time that he has if he's
trying to stay in this match with
Kuryakin
he needs to speed up and he needs to be
able to find the correct moves in a
short period of time because I'm just
saying the same thing over and over he
just said nothing I'm speaking of
platitudes and I'm just gonna make my
point in one sentence he needs to move
more quickly done yep no you're right
because several of these n games would
have been hold of II have had
more time on the clock right so you know
your your critical your being critical
of his time management earlier does come
back to haunt him and and you're not
wrong about that at all I think yep
and I mean we people made a brief combat
who is this just on the chest TV chat
James Coleman says video it was wasting
time and blitz but I went to overdrive
in a bullet I mean he crews in the
bullet you know so it is a different
game and perhaps did you show off some
might there and I like his position with
white miski just have some weak squares
that black has to deal with Knight g5 is
an option Bishop h6 or Bishop g5 and
both perfectly good moves black is not
developed fully well Duda hasn't played
as well as
Hakan with the white pieces he's down to
games in the match but he's also played
well given that the score is four and
half six and a half and both players
getting a lot of wins with white maybe
dude is gonna gonna come back and do the
same thing right now
I mean Bishop h6 Knight g5 this position
feels like it's playing itself yeah
and you know I have 10s on my mind after
going the US Open but essentially it
feels like they're holding served with
white you're right and then you know
with black they're trying to break and
it's been a huge hugely difficult task
from yellow okay so now c5 for black
it's like begging to be played but then
maybe Knight g5 and that's sort of the
issue is that night chief
you have 9595 just I mean Bishop see
through you take me five yourself Oh
everything's about undermining this
Knight here if you can you open the
diagonal here that makes sense but
Bishop c3 would be met by Bishop e5 so
maybe you put the rook on e1 first
Brigade e1 with the threat of Bishop to
c3 yeah he likes it I like it I like it
too we're all happy that's actually a
very instructional moment there yo and
queen c6 for black
okay you threaten a little maiden one on
g2 but why can't Sam Bishop b4 there you
can't live with them can't even move the
knight pinned down that is a problem
this move is risky but it was almost
forced I think rook a to e1 was was you
know almost winning and another move
that couldn't be played everyone was a
move like Bishop to e5 because their
white would just sacrifice the exchange
and then play Bishop to c3 once again
removing the night from f6 h5 here Queen
takes h5 Queen takes h5 problem book
mate find it find it find it oh my gosh
I love it I love it
that makes me had I love it makes me
happy because not every day you get a
position where all the sudden those
tactical patterns you've been working on
since a we young end right since a wee
lad you were a wee lad remember how I
taught you in a chess camp one time no I
you we've talked this every time I don't
remember Oh
selective memory just like my dad when I
talk about my childhood you're just like
my father
only remember what you want to well
right that was awesome that was flippin
awesome Queen takes h5 and that I mean
that has got to be a confidence boost
for Judah because yeah that's how you
went down here's the thing though you
made it made a point that they're
holding with the holding serve with
white somebody is gonna have to break
with black for the for the direction of
this match to change cuz right now you
know if Doodle goes down two games I get
again then we've just been here before
yeah I think the real key for Sergei is
you know okay well first thing we see a
French but let's just point that out we
have not seen the French and I guess
Duda is trying to move quickly and close
a position and just maneuver and try
that out place or get in that way but
you know Duda has been mixing it up a
little bit easily we got Sicilians out
French we've not seen the poetic we
haven't really seen a French get crushed
yet so that's one thing to mark off our
bucket list for this match no I don't
think the French is getting crushed yeah
I know I was gonna say we haven't seen
it get crushed yet and I don't think
we're gonna see a crush here shout out
to DM Captain Obvious who donates
because of the Queen takes h5 tactic if
there was ever a tactic worth donating
for you chose a good one that was
awesome so thank you there for the bits
that go to the players even if he loses
the match I'll let you to know that he
earned a donation just for that tactic
so that was awesome
I'm still not over it well you could
just see it coming right it was it was
one of those this is one of those games
you try to show kids of how pieces
coordinate together and develop toward
the Kings side and then you recognize
the potential the two bishops right and
then you get that like rare moment where
you actually get to finish off a well
developed attack with a brilliant move
so definitely fun and Dane in terms of
doing things that I don't like to do I
kind of like blacks position here I know
suddenly you like a fringe and you don't
know why it's like an identity crisis
yeah I'm not happy about it but I mean
I'm looking at the position and I see
this the Queen's eyes totally closed
down and there's only one pair of rows
which means that it's gonna be harder
for white to sort of initiate an attack
black on the other hand has this clear
target on the c3 square this night on c7
may either go a six to eight to be six
to a four
like better its are pressuring this III
swear yeah followed by Queen a fun yeah
I mean look at this control over the a
file the only open file on the board g5
is played both as a move to make
progress but also a bit out of
desperation yell because you're losing
on the queenside right you have no
choice counter play comes or you get
crushed over here positionally mmm-hmm
and so now the option okay f7 is hanging
so you have to figure out do I can you
play forward King e8 or do you just need
to go all-in
something like Queen a3 sacrificing f7
for c3 normally you'd be frowning upon
trading a healthy pawn for a weakness
but because c3 came with pressure - C -
I'm not sure that that wasn't the worst
idea for black yeah and here the you
know it goes can you get to keep
everything yeah I think it's the that's
the discipline move you want your
students playing right don't trade weak
pawns for healthy pawns overall this
looks great for by the man if I've
cannot be kicked yep and we'll see okay
what does correct me Tony no Queen f4
next and then I just want I'm willing to
get the Queen's off the board yeah Queen
yeah I like it I think just get pressure
to c3 in fact so much so that cardiac
and doesn't want to trade so did you
know Queen a to now is that there it is
okay and he's he's just trying to inch
his way
rook a3 if the workman was let's say did
you know each one rookie three four like
Queen B - I think he might bring the
rook to a3 anyway right that's sad
Brooksie one is not a move you want to
know it very sad pieces and and your
your plan you highlighted a while ago
this Knight eventually coming to a for
is is on the agenda so like Queen B to
hearsay 905 II takes five you've opened
up the e6 square for my night boo that I
like it that's uh that's Bronstein chess
for you yeah I'm trying to do my best
here I like Queen B to a lot because I'm
worried about Knight age for fishermen
we're now Queen's g5 isn't clearly I was
gonna say cuz the one way this game
backfires is if you somehow forget that
the dark squares are weak over here and
there are some infiltration points so I
think if okay he goes for Queen B - I
think this is the right idea the night
will come to e6 if traded where it
guards all the dark squares maybe goes
for f4 and even attacks the White King
in some positions
so we like it no this looks a great for
black and the real thing is there's no
way to make the progress necessary for
example tonight at 5:00 ef5 you need to
play queen a foreign key six in one move
but now after Queen it 496 you know if
you take the five queen takes c3 I think
and we're sliding sliding what d4 is
hanging and not now I can't take it now
yeah Queen C a check would be a problem
what takes you through is better
okay one hour okay one is B four can't
be too terrible the main thing you're
worried about if you're black is white
finding a way to swindle a perpetual
whether it happens with h6
opening up the f6 h8 diagonal whether
Queen f3 to d5 comes in so he plays
before but it's a little slow if Carrie
Aachen can do what he does with things
like h6 and create counter play yeah
actually one yeah what if he does that
and starts attacking what in the world
just happened there so uh I was
highlighting h6 for a counter play but
who's winning now I'm starting to like
white because I don't know how you're
gonna protect your king over there what
are you in remove do you make here uh
White's winning I don't see how you stop
rook takes h6 and this is weird okay
look that's happened real case every
time a rookie seven and like a shelter
himself with runs King and the thing is
black does have this past beep on which
is incredibly different with the style
yeah but now the whole the whole nature
of the game has changed this is more of
a traditional French for a whites
meaning attack is what matters
YouTube g5 doesn't that just win Bishop
g5 night can't take it cuz mate on c8
but this is also strong we highlighted
this earlier that d5 is a problem and
now by the way you can't even take on d4
because we're KJ comes with check first
and then Queen takes g5 comes with Tempe
yeah I think he's just he's just busted
something like Queen did she for
guarding d7 rookie Jade is made he goes
for it I like it so good Eve I'm King
now can da Bishop g5 of course
why is that okay so okay let's see just
make sense though Queens coming to see
it
eighty-six we no way no way you're
getting out of this Wow yeah the problem
is the Queen still out of play it's just
so out of play here it's not even one of
those positions where the knight
normally a good defender can do anything
to hold okay last last available try was
a perpetual of cardiac and didn't play
the right move but he did again white
hold serve and again we're right where
we were right neither player getting
wins or even or even really holding
draws right now is black right white is
good remember whoever all those books
like black is okay what about white is
winning in the French yeah when is
someone just gonna publish the title
with the most truth white is winning in
the French you know white was not
winning in that French that's for sure I
think something went wrong for kayaking
on the opening because do two seem to
equalize and then some yeah quite easily
but of course well the result held for
for Sergei and there's still and one
draw total which is just crazy concerned
they played 13 games I'd look at due to
mixing it up he's not playing efore this
games that plays Knight of three yeah
little new I'm actually kind of curious
on that because he's been scoring his
white maybe getting a little tired of
the Berlin thank God right about time
somebody got tired of it
nice III that's slightly unique way to
develop and this type of cattle and
structure I'll guess the pawn on d3 is
different though right not the
traditional Polland d4 yeah and the you
know black can't play c5 like you want
to because b5 hangs yep and if you
played be forever you're gonna be left
with some clear vulnerability and white
squares maybe up like forth so now
Knight to a 92 sort of speaks of me
still can't play c5 that's the nice
thing Tom Petty diamond member first of
all great name great artist rest in
peace but not the best comment he says
insane comment obviously my comment
about the French if it's so bad and
white is winning why do geum's like a co
being in volkov play the French almost
exclusively well firstly I'm pretty sure
that a Cobian switched away from the
French I was gonna say imma let you
handle this one yeah he plays a
character very fruitfully now I just
spoke with a French but that's not I
mean I don't know how to respond to them
and you know they both are very good
players and they are true to their
opening but that doesn't it doesn't mean
the openings good so yeah go go do this
Google search going go in your browser
yeah search CA are you a na it's Caruana
and then look up a Cobian is black and
look what happened at the u.s. champ is
a good reason why we don't play at the
highest level but okay let's let's keep
it on track here because we can go down
that road a lot all right the anyway we
we do appreciate the support though but
doesn't change our feelings on the
French Tom Petty as much as I love that
you be free-falling right now love it
right he won't back down Danny you know
what he's not gonna back down
even if he's free falling and help me
help me no I'm not helping you I'm
letting you freefall yeah the the move
before it comes undermining we have a
pin and this is an annoying thing about
having the block against any Catalan
okay this is a little bit different yeah
but having black and these kind of
setups like okay I did everything I the
books told me to put my queen on b6 I
coordinated my rooks towards the center
you know everything seems right but then
I have to worry about some weak pawns
position so yeah the one
counter-argument is if all that happens
with these pawns is a trade and you're
not able to win the beef I pawn then you
know black has a past B pawn and your
majority isn't as effective over here in
the center but I agree with you it feels
like even moves like rook a one switch
the Queen to the B file if we can target
the b5 pawn
and win these two for just the single
pawn then then why it's just you know
why it's just much better this is this
is what Duda will try to do here I want
to play Queen B - but then you take with
tempo
I can't how do i how do I get the
pressure I need against the b5 fun karak
and getting counter play on the C file I
mean we talked about maybe due to having
a chance to hold serve in the last game
as black or at least maybe brakes are
using our reference but maybe car Aachen
is gonna be the one that does so this
looks really tricky for white what do we
do here yeah it looks kind of dangerous
actually I don't really see how to
protect everything because pawn takes e5
there's problems like you said right
down the C file d3 can be targeted as
well
I beat 65 Knight c5 so it's Queen B 1
giving up the beef of mine this is a
good decision yeah because it takes you
can play 98 - right that's gotta be the
idea yeah and you know you black gets
the doubled past be pawns but at the
same time they're gonna be targeted and
white has a very strong center so that's
good news and yon bargeman looked at the
game Caruana Cobian and said that was a
massacre yep exactly
so okay Queen III a Queen b3 it got a
trade
Black's gonna try to come into c2 at
some point No ooh look at that the
maneuvers continue I like it I like it
you like it
Mike he likes it Oh Mikey now no just
the reference to the old the old
commercial according to Mike line
speaking of Mikey behind the scenes says
white has won seven games in a row now
so we're not exaggerating in terms of
what we've said about white holding
serve and where this is headed because
right now black has yet to prove that he
is okay he or she is okay it wasn't 95
okay no but even this still feels good
for Duda because the b-pawn feels like
much more of a target than an acid at
this point and again if it can be
corralled without counterplay getting
too much on the D file why should be
better but there's the be pawns really
annoying the digitized I thought I could
win Knight e5 and at the very worst boss
Knight to c4 let's say or try to bring
his rook to a7 and it's a which position
here instead of instead of instead of
rook D to C 1 95 94 ok I'll buy it yeah
that might have been better
let's try over K 7 and try to play like
that because now it looks like White's a
little bit on the defensive here yeah
okay nice c2 now is a threat hitting the
Brooke and the beep on but Brooke c3
stops that threat and now from Knights
Eaters between a 4 and I can't even play
92 because d3 falls so you got to go to
C - well Queen it forwards are nice
things before 95 or 94 wait yeah and
then Queen D 141 mission before rookie
whoa whoa Bishop takes e4 wasn't looking
for it pawn is pinned you couldn't take
it cuz the Queen would trade in c2 fell
this is a problem that's a nice trade
for black getting rid of that pawn for
the b-pawn means that they do the long
diagonals forever open whoa this is
hassle lose a piece Queen d7 check Queen
B seven oh yeah three was possible okay
but still d3 is falling here and and
this is the kind of game that black can
push for ever for a win because the
night is so much better than the bishop
with everything on one side of the board
time time being the one thing that could
probably make this game go wrong here
for black yeah I'm trying to honestly
but no this is like what a brilliant
transition this move Bishop takes e4 by
Carian was a great find
and the streak may be over yeah
we might be getting a win as black so
Queen of three only one second for do
defines the move rook d4 he's living off
the increment living on the edge
oh he mean there was no time left
literally no time but it didn't matter
cuz it lost a piece and Duda both of
them are losing time so this is
oh my gosh every time it's over and now
Kanak it only has one second Wow oh my
gosh
he's got Ritchie one car I can barely
defending now on the clock literally
living on the current that was 0.1
second that this is unbelievable she's
been a super crazy turnaround
Queen f3x recheck know he wants to get
the ladies off okay but now this
probably a draw H for 94-92 check King
Oh King eating before and he gets out he
can trade on g5 and then play a for q6
go run Forrest
this is so confusing Wow
I don't know how to feel right now you
know they have they have therapists for
those sort of things when you don't know
how you feel so g4 he's got jag kingi we
know h4 work rook 8 f8 okay I think
words when it's got to be winning now
the night is just no match for the
Brooke and this type of open board very
nice technical move Wow White has won
eight games in a row that was
ridiculously was headed sir gays
direction and then rook a 1 was played
and the crowd went wild I mean I almost
jumped out of my chair first there is
you know over 5,000 I know I took a lot
of heat for calling the blunders by
Dominguez Perez and I swear I didn't say
Brooke a1 this time because of it I saw
rookie one coming and I was about to say
well he better not play Brooke a1 boom
wow that is fortune so I mean off the
top of my head Duda has received two
very fortunate wins that one yo he was
dead lost and that one's Brooke f4 check
and crack and blundering this rook f-84
h8 stuff in game two so two very
fortunate wins we do - of course he's
had some great position that he's also
squandered so it's not like it's a ok
action would be crushing him no this has
been a very you know even matchup and I
think the score pretty accurately
describes what's been happening yeah I
mean anybody who thought that this was
gonna be a runaway match including yours
truly I mean on the record or off the
record as a commentator I'm not really
supposed to give my opinion but I mean I
think for many for many reasons karaoke
has been considered the heavy favorite
not just because of what we know he's
capable of he's a former world blitz
champion and you know made it to the
semi-finals last year but he you know he
took care of both of his first two round
opponents who were Georg Meyer and Jana
pom knee Oishi respectively in in in
Mork & cleaner fashion than he's
currently being able to to play against
Duda right I mean those matches were
were Runaways for Sergey honestly yep
but not that not today that's enough
today Junior not today Junior yep and
right now I mean look at this position
look that bish must see to does that
look like a good piece to you I mean why
would you ask me something like that
well I just want to know how you feel
about it I don't want your honest
feelings all I know is when I get this
feeling I need ya I'm not I need I need
Jess you will healing thank you for
bringing me the chest you will healing
I've always wanted I'm glad you found
everything you needed and more yep so
what's going on here looks any end game
looks very good for black because not
only do you have this night nc5 which is
an amazing piece hitting be merry be
sick nowhere to go yep and you ever
movie I'm taking that night okay I was
gonna say that was that was not ideal
for white to let that trait happen now
we have good night versus stinky town
Bishop yep
and look at the pawn structure as well I
see these double pawns for white yeah
and I immediately think oh can i play b6
rook over to h8 g 5h four and this is
like this is this is like a dream
Capablanca ones hand and it had a happy
ending that's all I'm gonna tell you
that's where we're headed right now that
was an extremely good one kappa kappa
blanka getting excited in the grave
right now you are you're a problem you
know that the exact you're laughing to
yourself and that is your right an issue
[Laughter]
i'm thinking of something else they'd
love to talk about later but you're not
talking about anything okay no we're
talking all right we are talking okay
i'm and also easy
oh i was flooded i want a five yeah
say that would be less than ideal
there's a pawn hanging there all right
the King comes to c3 what's Kuryakin
doing to wiggle his way to another white
victory rook t4 Brooke d1 and King
before there's this outside chance that
White's two-on-one actually becomes the
critical feature here okay outside
chance rook e8 was strong all a couple
Blanca king e5 yeah I'm trying to figure
out what happens if white goes f4 check
interesting Lee not not a movie you want
to play facing this monstrous what is
due to doing with the G he's just trying
to make sure these these weaknesses are
fixed right and look at this bishop I
mean by playing g4 you're saying this
Bishop is never gonna find some some
life yep so wait so g f3 g fe rook g8 is
very tempting yeah even repeat first
just to build on the tension first right
yeah you have to be worried about a 5
but well you know what's interesting is
he's pointing out that the knight is
doing everything it needs to right now
so that he can switch to the king side
and not be worried about counter play
but we're gonna find out if he was wrong
about that I think that was a huge
mistake so what's in it a 5 calm yeah
and now the rooks coming to h7 and the a
pawn is crazy
so the good news for black is the bishop
can't gets that diagonal so after a 6
Jack King aid sure white can force a
draw work age 7 or get shade etcetera
but I don't think due to sound happy but
a draw but in this type of end game you
need to play a six for white as a king 8
here yeah we'll take on b6 that's
actually a big problem yeah just take on
b6 and penetration well you can't go
night b7 because then there's okay the
Knights not actually under attack
because you take them and I have rooks
III check so that was the good news
this is key everybody cuz the night
couldn't go to d7 or sorry b7 wasn't
Brooke here obviously can't go to d7 so
this position is much more on edge for
blackened but once again we should have
seen a victory by black maybe with due
to having the edge most this endgame but
I'm not sure we're gonna see a victory
by black
yep and are you down on time for the
first time in a millennia
do you see jumper thong you foresee
what's up JB and the Chad he goes dude
Oh where's my car
pretty sure somebody already made that
joke but why I didn't see it earlier
because there were some other do to
jokes but we're not gonna go into that
dude oh yeah you stop it young man stop
it
Knight goes back to d5 here comes the
Bishop to b3 right yeah 95 take take
this it's a draw yeah all right I mean
Judah might still be wanting to play for
a win here that's true but how do you do
that because you're mad enough for needs
to stay there to protect the e6 I guess
you can play e5 but something worries me
about like trying to prolong this game
too much maybe e5 is good
the Bishop needs to find a way to the
headlights score diagonal and and I
don't see how he settles he settles the
safe call drawing with black is a good
thing in this match it would be the
first time white hasn't won in like we
said a really long time although let's
not speak too soon because I don't think
Rick d2 is the right idea
I just played d4 I think you'd give up
both the pawns in okay yeah all right
yeah well I should not be able to lose
this game f3
yeah it doesn't really matter but the
one way this goes wrong is b7 you try to
check when you don't have those steel
matrix where you sack the rook cuz you
have the extra fun so if white could
play b7 and then get the team to b6
black is losing wait a second Oh Magoo
should not his rookie six thankfully I
mean if you didn't have this I'd hang a
five f3 never again six okay Brooke h6
good enough right you go to Phil door
old-school Philidor should be a draw
now the rook comes back you get the
pawns in front and you flip around and
the king has nowhere to check so that
was instructive important to see how
black maintained his cool and defended
that so we have our first non-white
victory in nine games as crazy
yeah that that's a huge save there just
right now with the white pieces okay
he's going with d4 again so due to
switching it up playing d4 and well he
needs to play quickly in the open to
keep the initiative going here he just
made a draw with the black pieces which
is first time in dozen games and right
now he's got white so there's something
I got to give a shout out to Tom Petty
diamond member called him out when I
disagreed with his French coming but he
just said as Stephen Tyler said Duda
looks like a lady fan man all right dude
no no that's it's pretty good okay a lot
of beer
speaking of looking like a lady though
we got to go check in with our Twitter
contest a one-year diamond membership on
the line everyone let's uh let's see
what the latest tweets are where has
Sergey Karjakin been put Luis over there
in our Spanish broadcast just he is that
he is the best following is the most
loyal most amazing following on the
Internet
we got to go really far to see where our
contest is here we go a Sergei Princess
Leia that's pretty good not sure if it's
time in membership worthy yet there we
go it looks like something Sergei would
do poke around the corner and there we
go but I want to see Princess Leia
playing chess you know that's what I
want to say anyways it's so funny but in
this game speaking of chess
I'm laughing at all those hilarious
images but you know here we see that
cardiac room with the black pieces set
up this Queen and Bishop on the long
diagonal which is really annoying from
White's point of view because you want
to play 92 but you can't play nighties
here when g2 is hanging in was on h2 so
kam could be a useful move at some point
the key which I made sure you could then
put 90 to go cousin Bishop GG of f3
trapping that Bishop in on the GT square
Z one yeah yeah plays 91 which is just
to get this night off to have three
square to play f3 and potentially for
buddy 5 it's exactly how you want to
target that and
do two plays Bishop of three almost a
bailout move because I don't think White
has any an edge anymore yeah if you do
have an edge is very very small so
you're essentially hoping to play
against this b-pawn Joan you it's not
the size that counts forever
an edge and it is an edge try and get it
Oh Danny what am I going to do with you
so let's see takes takes it's still an
edge yeah it's one of those annoying
edges especially as a time patrol
shortens you might show with because
you've had a weak bond for black whereas
west palm know I'm very nice but just
like Queen before here or take on you
for first try to try to put the ending
game I played Queen before trying to
keep the Queen's on the board because
Bishop e4 oh actually there might
mission before you can't play Queen you
for was work on getting sufficient
before does not win the bishop before 94
Queen takes b6 I'm wondering what Duda
is thinking about but Duda comes through
Big Lebowski yep take them b6 the
problem is whether there's gonna be
seventh rank counter play maybe the
world comes to d2 but you got to be
super okay he goes for it I was gonna
say you got to be super cautious in
situations where your own back rank
becomes a problem but but he goes for it
nonetheless how do you take advantage
here because yeah you want to be able to
put the Queen on a square that hits c8
right so you right right
nowhere to go so when those weird
positions where a human being should be
scared to play moves like rook d2 right
but like you know we said the modern day
super GM doesn't doesn't have any of
those practical fears right because
computers would play rook d2 i'ma play
roof d2 I can defend yeah how does white
go for it
f3 93 and I'm starting to see ideas with
h5 is for and inmate metal there's an
immediate for chemo happening into a
shed but
h5h for cement the night on g3 and look
for things i mean why just has nothing
because if you trade the queen's off the
board look at that known you want
where's that going stuff so i think why
does not even better here who queen b8
take g3 but I can't because my rook
falls mm-hmm
is so scary so if I can't come queen bee
Aida I can maybe check and then go back
to b3 try to force the Queen's off the
board yeah May Queen b3 first same idea
I just okay David be a check later yeah
if black blunders and doesn't attack my
rook now I'm winning a piece trades h4
I'm guessing put the kibosh on that
maybe ninety yeah 93 as well 93 looks
good as well if you yeah but he says no
thank you
even at the risk of losing the H pawn
it's interesting because if e4 Knight h4
rook b5 Robert yeah if you have to play
g6 to guard h5 your knight on h4 is
actually trapped in fact I think he's
gonna I like that idea he's going for it
yeah the knight actually is not super
idea of there okay I think black should
be okay like night h4 I've ever seen one
what's a rook c2 and not losing g2 pawn
no but the knight was on e1 yeah he's
making a draw I don't know huh that was
I was hoping for white to sort of limp
out of that position into an advantage
he no Keyser söze style but he doesn't
do it yeah it looks like just king
before here and yeah okay this is like
the alternate ending usual suspects
where Keyser söze was just nobody
nothing happened yep
I love that movie by the way so thank
you for reference you're welcome
you only great memories by the way of4
he says no he's only got 12 seconds I
mean his cardiac I'm gonna push this one
now probably right why not with only 9
minutes left very good chance that this
is the second-to-last three-minute game
we're seeing no matter what the result
and that was a very necessary pawn push
by Duda because there's threats of night
rookie to check 92 to g3 that looked a
bit annoying and now now I think they'll
just take a tickle over one chicken
please well why not men to five now
here's now we've notified that way I
don't know a day that was looking really
scary the the the game ends peacefully
despite the best efforts for a decisive
result 95 was a good move there I would
have played on I already tried two of
these I don't disagree with you jokes
aside yeah especially given that White
was lower on time so okay what is this
so c5 the idea for black to c5 like why
would you put your name before well
yours the 93 I guess but when the
Catalan you're having a night there is
not the worst thing in the world right
I'm not menacing that's not the worst
thing
no I agree it was a weird opening by
black and likely we're headed to getting
the white train the wind train back
again right because white one there was
12 decisive games in a row for those of
you just joining us and white won the
majority of them these guys have had a
lot of decisive chess today and now it
looks like Corey Aachen getting to
better opening here again is white yes
slightly better though at the same time
it's it's uh
I know jump Bartholomew is out there
somewhere what kind of setup business
look like what kind of pawn structure
scandi hashtag team scandi that's right
up and so that means black is extremely
solid but lacking space yeah and so if
you're at a player who likes to cower in
the corner and just like let your
opponent walk all over you and then
eventually survive I love that that
not-so-subtle Jeff oh man I hope let's
hope John is still here there he goes no
John will admit and we've been telling
of this since he was a kid
nobody likes taking abuse more than John
and then and then somehow working his
way out of it I'll never forget when I
was told by the late and great Emery
Tate to get in there cuz the kid needed
me and it just it's just so like not fun
to play as black here right you just
like have no space no and you're like
but it's great in blitz cuz his eyes as
I've proven it's really easy to screw up
clear edges against y'all Bartholomew
over and over again oh absolutely you
know I think it's very hard to beat but
the mindset in the skin and Haven is
often like okay you're like you're like
come get me come get me big boy come and
get me right I know I'm worse I know I'm
worse you're like the little kid in the
playground who challenges the bigger kid
to a fight and runs in circles and hope
that he doesn't catch is really attire
you give him one kick in the shin and
then you run away again like that's sort
of the mindset I feel like what with the
skin now I hope black wins just for
John's sake and just for the fact that
we finally get to see a victory for the
second player cuz Black has not been
okay in today's speech yes match and
okay so let's see Bishop takes okay you
want to ruin the pawn structure but this
again one of those positions where the
d4 pawn is a potential target but
black's pawn structures an obscene that
ideal some night at five okay rook e1
yeah i mean no you're right it's a
comfortable edge for white will there be
enough or will do to prove team scandi
proud and just let the let the structure
get better and better for white until
eventually somehow white blunders how it
feels right now right
I mean John such a nice guy I feel a
little bit bad no I don't that's candy
and so we all know it's about love here
and John by the way will will be having
while you and I are doing the main
coverage of the World Chess Championship
this November we said that John will
have a special show that I'm gonna
predict may end up being one of the most
watched things on the web in November
because John is gonna be breaking down
games on like a real deep educational
level cuz he is he's probably the best
chess teacher I know John it's gonna say
it he's very good at teaching chess
Robert you're good to calm down but
you're a commentator you're an
entertainer first John's a teacher first
I mean I've been trying to teach you to
tame your jokes for years now really
that's why you're not such a good
teacher exact night at 4:00 okay but
again John this is this has got to be
making your steam scandi skin crawl
right now dude hey this is just this is
just getting abusive for black well
relax trying to go for some counterplay
logo things aren't going my way let me
try to sacrifice my rope for that night
and he's going to but it's over anyway
wait a second night of six okay where's
that Queen Lynette to h3 yep you cook g5
is better queen h3 what point can try to
sacrifice my pieces yeah I mean is c5
hangs it's not the end of the world Lucy
five honestly yes the biggest issue is
just that positionally black there's now
White has the pollen and the
compensation right now I'm saving just
cleanup one you'd meet cleanup 123 Queen
f2 Queen takes f4 watch out oh I missed
that very nice you freaking called it oh
[Laughter]
that's how black wins in the
Scandinavian take note everybody that
right there is how black wins in the
Scandinavian oh boy and somehow someway
I knew black was gonna win this game
black was almost two points worse in
that position if you want to give and
evaluate
on it and suddenly the positions crazy
by the way why does rook t4 in this
position is it that CLE just played king
of what white okay
analysis not whitehead rook d4
oh wait a sec t4 look kinda nice Queen
e5 and then F 4 yep that was a missed
opportunity
he was so shot baby was so it again it's
just the scan D strikes back
you have to Queen D money for the Oval
might have had to play like 94 or
something just like survive yeah I think
it was probably close to equal but the
point is that white wasn't losing no
yeah I agree definitely agree well now
we're have a tied match unless something
goes and we said it earlier and then
crackin blender to work on a1 right but
here if black finally gets a victory
well it'll be the first time I mean am I
guess my client will come up with a stat
here isn't me the first black victory in
a really long time
and we're gonna have a tied match which
nobody would have called so and probably
it'll be tied head into bullet which
will be for the only set the second time
in history right we just talked about
that that we had only had one other tied
match and then vidit ran away with it
against zabun Audrey Oceana but Joe well
I guess so can't believe it I love how
it it's like fake credit since candy
because like all the scan you won the
game not that nothing to do it this is a
lot like how the French wins hilarious
all right so okay black should win this
that's all this should happen here yeah
and they're trying to figure out what
instructional point to make and I'm
struggling because it just looks so easy
for black I mean you know he's being
slow progress he has to watch out for
his clock but he's doing a pretty good
job up right now
playing a5 a4 was a great idea just to
create a clear weakness to attack and so
he puts a pawn b3 up over 55 now I can
play rip to be fourth check yeah g6 come
on yeah come on black get a victory rook
g6 check oh no
okay Nike forest 94 is juicy maybe I
keep asking for stats but then making
fun of him so my client wants me to get
smarter she has to be stat boy since I
love him more anyway dad yeah but no we
love you Mike and blacks about to get
that first victory that we talked about
and I think it's probably gonna be
enough to get another three-minute game
just we're getting so much extra chest
today cuz black is about to win this one
Sergei playing on for kicks and giggles
at this point I mean it's just over yeah
just have to be careful not to blunder
your pawn before p5 check there's 95 or
teen d6 it's 96 and it's over yeah it
would be a resignation soon if I may be
caught in trying to play maybe he wants
to get to bullit only a few more seconds
actually and he gets to bullit do you
think he knows how much time I don't
know if it's Matt strategy or not but
he's about to he's about to force this
match into bullet if that's what he was
trying to do my guess is no and he just
believes there's outside chances of a
blunder because he's not wrong right but
what's do I mean you know I'm gonna look
at it as I mean at this point the game's
not ending in 10 seconds I'm guessing
unless he resigns right there I thought
he was about to what students bullet
rating here I'm trying to find that
right now yeah he's he's been playing a
lot on this site you played the title
Tuesday this week and just like that
reef that's it that's it this game this
game doesn't count we're gonna abort it
the time ended yeah okay we have a judge
for this reason who's not me okay the
judge says yes it's time for bullet and
the reason why we have a judge so that
we can we can just be commentators and
let's go bullet black just got his first
victory in however many games Mike lines
about to tell us we have our next three
minute break so don't go anywhere and
for the second time in speech Chess
Championship history the match is tied
hitting a bullet last week that was a
blowout even though the match was tied
him to bullet
I have no idea we're about to see but
we're gonna be right back and figure
that out
stay tuned all right well right as we
get started for Bullitt and we still
have so many of you with us more than
6,000 of you tuning in as you should be
it is a tied match with the underdog
maybe pulling a huge upset but tomorrow
we have Geary versus Mahmoud er of all
6,000 of you should be here and your
friends and cousins and best friends
lawyers uncles roommate and if you're
not we're coming after you Robert
here we go let's get the party started
30 minutes of bullet under way I think
I'm not I'm ready to get jiggy with it
yeah and I see it eight and a half eight
math and right now it's starting we see
resorting back to a Berlin four car
yakking and well well seem to to has
like has what it takes because he's
clearly a very talented player did
actually about the same brain thousand
the twenty nine ninety three but due to
not always the quickest and the blitz
portion in the opening segment
Gary's playing instantly which is
obviously important yep more time on the
clock then they started with both of
them and I'm actually just telling Danny
I was telling some of the
prognosticators that I told them that
this match would be extremely close you
know people were thinking that karyakin
would be the heavy heavy heavy favorite
and yes maybe he is the favorite but I
thought it would be a good battle indeed
right now this is what we've seen in
fact this was from we saw this structure
earlier right I don't remember what game
it was but we definitely saw earlier
that pawn went to c4 and white played
just like to mention when h4 and the
pawn made its way to h5 so looking solid
this is an exact and this is exactly
what we seen I don't think anything has
changed yeah I was gonna say this is the
game where we were first sort of semi
critical of white giving black the D
file and the pawns being stuck but he
was eventually able to figure out h5 and
g4 and this game car Dawkins says no
thank you on that
with the move g6 so that's key so but
now okay now some of the dark scores are
a bit vulnerable
you can play Knight to g5 at some point
you protect your ePHI upon first my
point is that if I can play rook you ad
you won then Knight to g5 I take you
trade on g5 at point Bishop on f6 then I
play g4 h 5 etcetera so you have to be
very very careful here if you're if
you're black you oka one slight time
advantage for karyakin on the 10 seconds
it's not slight at all anymore and and
we'll need to see what's what black has
in store because 83 stops before saying
if you go before I'll take eight eggs
before trade those eight pawns and then
come after your c4 pawn and that's what
still going for here rook d3 is nice
tonight is the night today is the match
where two heads become one Robert you
can't even see the difference between
those two on the graph that's how close
this match has been despite Kuryakin
being so heavily favored just had to
show that yep and crazy I was reading a
comment from an upset comments or on
Twitter saying upset that we're saying
how close the match is going to be when
it literally is eight and a half eight
and a half and time so that's an
interesting moment to get upset about
all right well only the fun thing about
this is this is exactly the Berlin we
saw when both players had four minutes
on the clock now they've got 15 seconds
so how will they handle that it looks
like Duda is gonna get his plan first I
feel like a Harry is like we said well
why did he do anything he blundered I
think he wanted to go for cage to and
he'd blender the h4 pawn and they both
missed it Luke h4 was hanging the whole
time Atkins rated he could have just
taken on h4
exactly and now that H pawn is about to
run okay he's gonna trade once and then
h5 yep black I want the King in front of
it though King f8 g 8 h7 he agrees with
this idea the problem is it should be
once play it's to play move admission be
one and hopefully takes before I think
he wants to go for a mating that at some
point with Bishop h4 Bishop sex ooh
but maybe coriaci gets the bait first
night at 5:00 check never take on so
long just take oc5 I forgot well that's
not the bishop
it's a Bishop f4 okay Brooke h5 also
possible and I guess he's that his idea
is that if you take on sheath wait a
second old age for he would say he just
missed it Corey I can just missed this
dude yeah are we about to see is this
really about to happen
oh I mean like seriously I mean I given
given that we've never really seen an
upset of this magnitude in the speed
chess championship and given karaoke and
being so heavily favored as a potential
winner of the whole thing honestly many
people's pick along with a card on come
more to make the finals
yep this would be this would be the
upset for the ages call your friends
tell your mom that you're busy watching
games on Twitch like bah I'll take all
the garbage in a minute I'm watching
twitch nice I like your little Will
Ferrell rest oh stop with the video
games
I'm not playing video games mom I'm
watching chess Danny speaking of chess
we see another French how do you feel
about it I think it's really bad for
Black Widow probably wouldn't you know
is actually this type of position is
quite interesting because the position
is very locked up right White has the
advantage of the Queen side and that you
have a little more space and the center
of the pawn to e5 looks good but you're
sort of stuck and you know what you
thought White's doing playing for g4
black or black should try to play B v a5
I don't know what's yeah there we go
let's go feeling I've got to play for B
5 and a 5 but Corey Aachen has really
put himself in a position where now due
to believes he can do it right yeah this
is the the position you don't want to
put underdogs in where they actually
think they can win absolutely and now
after the night if an that goes to c5
you have to chop it off and you put b4
here you put a 5 first okay Bishop d7
that of course makes sense you know how
to keep your King protected if you can
protect your king yeah look at that on
f4 the bish 1 d2 is stuck for Terry a
week you and importantly the bishop on e
2 needs to jump over to g4 in one move
but it takes some time by night where if
I didn't know any better I'd say you're
talking good about the French air
well I'm talking about this specific
position certainly not the opening you
know and you know it's difficult for for
white here because okay well now I don't
know it's a rookie tribe I guess only
move and how do you continue this attack
very nice defensive setup here for the
moment from black Bishop p8 can come in
to the game at some point soon
III just yeah but yeah the pawns on the
Queen Sutter just running wild wait take
that on a to maybe take on a to you and
play Queen B - is that that's sitting on
the structure which also makes sense
just because white can never really take
without giving black to passed pawns
over here but but I agree taking and
playing Queen to be two was the other
the other perhaps more aggressive
approach you gotta hate to have this
pawn structure from White's front point
of view I mean look at this is menacing
but at the same time you actually can't
promote any of your pawns that Bishop
one he wants you might think we'll
playing Bishop d12 c2 he's first closing
everything up so it takes that each for
he has Bishop into f3 at some point okay
F force weak but again the thing that's
been interesting is the time scramble
right at this point you've kind of are
y'all can way down on the clock this is
not a good transition at all King g8 to
f7 coming but your pieces pull it out
well it's okay because it's the game
this game is over at this point just
take any old King f7 take Bishop d1
bishop c2 actually don't wanna play
Bishop c2 yet there's no reason to take
on upstairs he's gonna trade on f5
that's smart
the very nice wood that passed beat the
bullet it's gonna be all that matters
yeah rook d7 okay I heard that you just
swing in his rook around
it's over and with no time on the clock
and a b-pawn to deal with karaoke and is
gonna be down to games and bullet and
after black not winning any games and
due to not having a leading the match
since game four he's about to have a
two-game lead in bullet yep this is uh
pretty huge and those pawns are not
being stopped this is amazing this is
this is an upset like I could not have
predicted and you know I don't want to
say it again but I've been sticking up
for Duda this whole time so you have you
have I mean Duda is uh when we know his
potential we know that he's a rising
star but there's no way that even with
the the potential there that you know
most people are gonna be seeing Sergey
Karl can leave in the first round of the
SEC so no way yep and okay we have
another exchange Spanish position this
time the Queen's have not been treated
so early and what black wants to do is
unravel on the Kings side and you get
the piece that developed fully th one
with some nice moves include that way
you can avoid Bishop h3 with a pin on
the G file and after these ideas with f5
this was just played ok f3 solid now if
you take on e4 I take with my knight get
development going and you know you hear
a five like not an idea you want to play
from blacks point of view because Queen
a6 comes to check and it looks like a
very shaky Queen side if I would think
I'm playing rook to b1 and the idea
being I at some point I want to play
Queen a6 sacrificed my nine play d4 and
just blast open the position so here
okay just continues making progress in
the center but Corey Aachen doing very
well to shore up that Queen side well
and really for the first time he's
playing much faster here up on the clock
yeah so that's very big and I mean it's
position is just great plenty of time
still with twenty minutes in the total
match I mean there's no way did this is
the match is probably ever gonna be out
of the range of either player winning it
given how close it's been but with Duda
winning three games in a row
Kuryakin has to stop the bleeding
yeah I don't love what's happened here
from for white because I thought that
there was some initiative to be had on
the queenside and to try to play for an
attack and maybe sacrifice a piece but
again some they're not my pieces so it's
easier for me to just throw them away
but right now we'll say Black has formed
a stable blockade and g5 just start
pushing on the side of the board the
bish 1 b7 is a monster the Kings side
looks like it's collapsing for white you
know Nathan wasn't doing anything so
every time y'all can just strike back
just like Princess Leia would I knew
your and knew I was waiting for the
moment you would say that
and you found a very good time to do so
I got yeah it looks like he's uh you
know what for this night to move and
then for this diagonal become 99
problems and diagonals are multiple
multiple of them a girlfriend ain't one
but the diagonal is nice attempt to
blockade the diagonal yeah it is though
he's gonna play Knight to g2 may be
queen of one but now your completed ship
h4 and Bishop h4 up by Knight g2 and
just kicked a bishop away
yeah there's nobody White's holding this
really okay now now I thought Bishop h4
would have been stronger trade Queens I
think by King g3 Bishop h4 has to be
played there you go yeah this take
employee to take completely - right Oh
II 6 it has to get back he brings the
King over but now you can take and play
you - right yep absolutely he's taking
his sweet time but it's irrelevant
because White's why didn't he take him
play you to a move before he missed it
and now and now Knight c2 check and when
he 300 my god I could have just taken
and play t2 but when the King was on g1
yeah
what in the world everything going south
for Sergei everything going south for
Sergei today this has not been the same
level of chess we're used to seeing but
that's what happens right I mean clearly
he's rattled
they both miss d6 there's some side
there you go and apparently someone
someone missed out on proper safety
measures because there goes an amulet
well here comes s you can't go you seven
cuz you know and see everything yeah but
you're gonna find a way to do it
ye seven bank it's just ridiculous to me
what's happening here and also Sergei
missed that instead of Bishop g2 you're
gonna play Bishop g4 to h5 to stop that
palm from queening so like literally
every is not not the best chefs we've
ever seen from mr. Kuryakin and you
called it you said that he hasn't been
in great form didn't play well in the
Sinquefield Cup didn't defend positions
that we are accustomed to seeing
although looks like he did just defend
this one to it but uh or I think so I
think he's defending this yeah the white
king will go to the corner and then no
sacrifices knife for the F oh yeah okay
sorry guys just gonna allow it because
what's the point in what's the point in
fighting although now I have to be
careful because okay he's just gonna
sacrifice the night for the f1 okay yeah
in fact the stalemate that's the owner
instead raw as they say just add water
instant raw well yeah okay but that was
Sergei Kuryakin scheme to win as black
easy win with trading and playing E -
right we weren't crazy about that missus
that misses several other chances at the
Wow
this is um this has been his moment dude
uh you know it's just
yo mom's spaghetti mom spaghetti you
know card I could really should have
something in positions like this where
white is just pushing through attacking
possibilities and I like his decision
thick with a deep on he's he's a plant
his night on the d4 square at some point
wait what's going on 94 94-94 Pondy for
to a five-point falls maybe yeah no this
this has got to be better for wait
somehow that did not go well with the
pin action for those wondering again why
we've been talking so much about why
this is such an amazing upset gonna be
the biggest in Sec history
if young Christoph Duda can hold on I
mean nothing explains it better than our
odds odds graph and you see
different direction that that those two
projected finishes are going as far as
the underdog really just showing that
not everything is about ratings on paper
sometimes you have it on a day and you
don't and Sergey hasn't had his best
chess but young Christoph has had some
awesome chess so great stuff although I
feel like I feel like Sergey is gonna
get this one I like G for Robert
especially with this work on a3 spying
the elevator take the lift to the H file
yep and super dangerous things happening
over there and it's you know this white
is the one who could push to pass pawns
to keep on you know if finger trader the
beep on whereas black has the ANC pawns
that are totally blockaded from time
being yep I think Gina's putting pretty
stubborn defense here though this
27 is really nice to hold the a4 pawn
down I guess you could swing the bishops
and d1 if you're white and say I'm just
negotiating table yeah he wants to swing
the Queen I think over to this diagonal
and hit d5 I actually really like this
plan by Sergei put the Queen on g2 it
hits d5 there should be one mister do
you on Wednesday for should be one
gobbles up we didn't see it or he does
and he knows he has plenty of time plays
Bishop to c3 now he can play Bishop d1
it's only a matter of time before that
pawn falls Bishop c2 and then bring the
Queen to f3 and d1 this man Bishop d7
it's actually surprisingly tough b5 he
just missed it it's a double attack
going to be one hit f5 and threaten b5
karak and will strike back and you know
we were what I was gonna say we were in
the range of almost potential
mathematical danger for Sergei because
if if doodle won this game right then he
would have been up three games with less
than 15 minutes left but it looks like
Sergei will get his first victory in the
bullet portion huge win for Sergei I'm a
humanist assuming he pulls it off at
this point it would be it would be the
most shocking thing of the match so far
if he didn't
but it looks like he he will he should
Queen to see one Czech Bishop f1 okay
doesn't matter and Network a1 yep good
enough trading Queens not gonna help
could do to plain this one out probably
match strategy at this point he has to
know that he's in the driver's seat and
and is on his way
yeah this is a this is a pretty easy
conversion at this point but you're
right match strategy just make sure that
you lower the clock say to cardiac and
you're gonna you're still down a game I
get the white pieces in the next one and
crack it needs not to lose this one yeah
you can't just do me this one the next
game we're making sure the players are
aware with only 12 minutes and 45
seconds left what the situation is with
every game and I think they know that
when they see that little number next to
their avatars they know it's a very
close match overall but making sure
they're also aware of the time right
this is a been a much more exciting
match than we thought to be and at this
point we wouldn't be surprised to see
the most amazing upset yeah and I mean
look at this car yeah Ken getting into a
Spanish where black has slightly less
space why can it move pretty easily but
I really think from cardiac in support
of view he'll just be happy not to lose
because both sides been winning with
white in like all of their games yep
so just holding is just such a
tremendous thing and I compared the
tennis and it really way to d5 coming it
no there's a fishpond b7 that stops me
complaining do you find like I want so
the only counterpoint to that is at this
point with the match strategy every
every game taking a lot of time off the
clock here I mean this is you want to
get victories if you're Sergei you're
right holding a draw with black here
you're assuming he's gonna get more
chances with white but but okay I'm
nervous I don't even know why it's the
butterflies butterflies I have none of
those I'm just you know trying to figure
out a way to break through for either
side because right now it's one those
tense positions no pollens have been
traded
take on e5 you open up the D file and
black is the one who's primed to take
over that one if you ever take on d4 you
give white great control over the center
so it trades a knight paramedicine h5
and here for white you can consider
playing d5 now because the night is no
longer protecting that d5 square you
have to think about how does that impact
the game if c5 was inflated 55 so it's
anybody c4 and now create a b2 but yeah
but positionally the b-pawn seems to be
an easier one to target than the c6 pawn
although okay watch out now with the
Queen of the F file there's always
tactics
well the e5 pawn is weaker than the e4
pawn okay Boyan probably weaker than the
d4 pawn just because it takes a some
effort to put blacks pieces over to the
video sweat no you're right went a
different direction I was thinking is I
really like this eight this chief or
chief or idea where's my key or I don't
like this decision where's my g4 emote
there it is a very dangerous decision by
Kuryakin because opening the G file yes
it will benefit him if he can get his
rook to g6 let's say or you know gets
the H file but right now if that Knight
moves itself and f3 VOC g3 as a threat
so 9h know nice yeah nice to hear is not
HT to a really good move
here comes rook to g3 you're right and
rook g3 coming huh surprised he didn't
play with g3 first so because now watch
out for 92 check so that's it right out
of the simplification okay Queen h5 the
b6 pawn is pushing Queen edge - there's
a threat of rook c8 here yeah so I want
to go to Queen h2 and if Queen is to put
this Queen t1 there's still Queen D 1 is
open oh no so this queen is now putting
pressure on the e5 pawn that's nice move
judge 33 and here's the beep on black
probably doesn't have time for h5 & H 45
Dixie may be just blundered it yeah oh
my gosh nine minutes nerves of steel
game lead Duda
is tell you what he's not full of you're
so ridiculous oh my gosh he is on fire
right now this is ridiculous
Danny what do you make of this decision
to keep going back to this French that
has given white a nice positional
looking advantage every single time
Mouse live Mouse's live by sir he is on
Full Tilt right now
I never thought I'd say it I mean Sergei
is supposed to be the guy who doesn't go
there he doesn't get on tilt
you don't tilt Sergei he's the Teddy KGB
of the speeches championship but guess
what guess what he's doing right now
he's you know round it out you know what
happens at the end of that movie Teddy
KGB finally goes on tilt I mean yeah I
made a response that you missed Nimrod I
don't know I I heard it he got rounded
up I heard it don't don't ever don't
ever question your father's love for you
you're not my dad all right so okay well
i got nothing i got nothing because he
mel slipped kingi to king of two that's
what he got nothing
oh my god no but seriously if Duda can
just I mean look at him just close look
at him just close it up if he wants to
go Sasha Grichuk on this he could
probably make this game last for three
minutes yeah I mean seriously right this
is ridiculous
just like Bishop Miege do nothing you
could just do nothing and take 10
minutes off the game clock this could be
the match right here just take on g5 my
work age 7 or is he not gonna do that
he should yeah and he is yeah you take
with the f1 that's like his best chance
cuz now he can use the f4 square maybe
manufacture h5 you got to get some
strategic you know dynamic and balance
here but this is this is just it does
look good for white but it will take a
lot of time to actually you know really
make progress ok play 50 moves as fast
as you can
and in claim a draw that's hilarious I
mean seriously like right now he's
losing the match because because too
much time is gonna come off the clock
and he's down two games he has to win
this one and win again to send it to
overtime before the clock runs out and
what there's like six minutes and 40
seconds left so he does have time for
two more games after this so you're
right he just needs to get this game oh
well actually men of 696 looks pretty
good for a matter of six rook h3
territory everything on h3 so but he's
in mathematical must-win Theriault must
winter I just said Theriot God loves a
terrier as I said that the best-in-show
reference you don't know that one I
don't know I gosh Christopher guest's
dude wait Bishop takes d5 here does that
work wishing g3 first played Bishop g3
and taken before so you can have the
threat of e6000 the diagonal yeah taking
a queen d6 chekalin he's six yeah okay
Caracara I can has to win this game
though we are in a if a blunder happens
it's okay
65 he missed the 9065 is an option
because the problem is the Queen trade
would not have been good for he's just
want to see tactics everywhere man yep
Sergei is just not in best form and he's
running out of time to find it okay
still as Knight takes d5 there you go
there you go yeah you shake Queen d6
Chuck oh and sir here's two seconds left
I'd even notice yeah no he's he's way
down the clock he should be able to
gobble everything only one second though
check it all is he just gonna take a
draw he can't afford to take a draw he
has to win this game
yeah there's no time there's no time
though but he has to win okay now he
goes for it but it's not enough no it's
losing this should be five is the only
move now seven this is it we are
witnessing the first upset the first
serious upset and speech Chess
Championship history yep
look at this
wait the d5 here oh I miss D 5 D 5 in
Queen of six but he's been missing in
game sieves and missing things all day
yep
I mean this has just not been sir guys
best not at all and now it's over
Bishop f7 comes I guess now queen of
slain for that Queen oh no time oh wait
he found a move let's keep it but it's
made anyway Trey Queens get a Queen
yourself yeah I get a queen first yeah
oh yes you made on e3 or you you start
the meeting attack on e3 you won on time
that's it's over I mean three game lead
three game lead it's happening the upset
heard around the chess world yep and I'm
shocked about the lack of lack of emotes
here there we go
as if as if they heard my cry where is
the Duda spam sorry
I forgive you don't worry this is I mean
this is great just like this is just
absolutely crazy Danny when you add me
describe Duda at the beginning of the
match and I understood that he was a
relative unknown for more casual chests
friends for people who are you know it's
pretty significant chess fans of course
they know who Yan Christophe Duda is
yeah the phenomenal player 2740 that
number one polish player over in Floyd
table check is you know number 23 25 new
world the exact number and you know I
follow just extremely close you have
seen his success in Dortmund I've seen
his success in the Polish championship
he's beaten the void Todd checked
multiple times in recent wasn't that's
the cool thing much the hell does dude
again 20 so in comparison
[Music]
he's what three years younger then
then whom oh how do I even know what I'm
talking about I mean I was thinking MBL
and next semes 23 right
no Maxine's way older than that come on
yeah anyway yeah he's ridiculously young
given his potential here and of course
gotta give credit where credit's due
my boy Pete events coordinator who
normally spends his time obsessing over
Lila is currently obsessing over Yan
Christophe Duda and and reminding me
that it was his idea to make sure that
Duda got an invite to this year's SCC so
Cory I can't finding a nice tactic that
would be great enough you know in a
classical game where it's just these two
players playing but when you're down so
much time just not enough I never I mean
just never thought we would have been in
a situation saying that not enough for
car Aachen to get back run out of time
yeah you just thought and there goes the
wambulance yep somebody call the
wambulance if you're rootin for in
here
he needs it and this is a nice game
honestly buy him one of his better games
but one win is none to fend off Duda
because there's one minute and a half
left the EVAs if blacks gonna win this
game it's gonna take the rest of the
time on the on the match clock it's over
yep oh man unbelievable already excited
don't even know what questions to ask in
the in the chat but but Wow
people laughing at my age age issues
there but if I claim I'm 70 17 I clearly
look like I'm 45 right so got that got
those dad years on me better dad years
and dad beers I'm alright
better then dad you got nothing i got
nothing i got nothing because this match
has been just just crazy stick around
don't go anywhere we've lost about a
thousand of you in the last few minutes
because you're like well i saw the
biggest upset i don't need to stick
around for the interviews but you're
wrong interviews are coming and with it
questions will be asked yeah just first
time ever the underdog is moving on in
in crazy crazy dramatic fashion the
opposite of what we saw in last week's
match we're tied in to bullet we had a
runaway train this has been closed down
to the wire but the underdog moves on
and and that's it this game still counts
as far as the overall score but the
match is over y'all never self judah
will be taking on i don't even know yet
we'll check on the bracket in a minute
but but wow sirs wales rousers and very
impressive match by him so well you know
i can't wait to talk with the players
i'm gonna ask about the white color does
seem like they're just trading off wins
with white forever yep how many total
draws that they have - i think - yeah
not many at all and young christophe
judo will be moving on to face Sasha
Grichuk in the next round of the
speeches championship we are gonna do
our best to conduct these interviews
given our the technical issues we've had
throughout the day but what's amazing is
that drama exists and that's what
matters
we are joined here by Yong Kristoff as
well as Sergey Karjakin
can you both hear us yes I can
well an amazing match I think I speak
for Robert when I say this is this was
the most exciting match we've had all
year only the second time ever in speech
has championship history that a match
has been tied headed into bullet and
obviously Sergei I know this isn't what
you wanted to hear and not not your
favorite result of the day but the
biggest upset we've ever had and the
underdog moving on Sergei it didn't seem
like you just had your best chest today
did you find yourself struggling under
time pressure more than more than you
normally do and maybe share a little bit
about what went wrong here today against
you on Christoph well I think I played
quite quite badly I've made so many
blunders I mean I mean the way their
stupid blunders and so I was blubbering
ruined and to model things into winning
positions sometimes sometimes not in
doing but just majestic in in a normal
position and so it was it was hard to
keep playing and and actually I
understood very very quickly after after
after game to that time in a very bad
form but okay I was trying my best but
but also also I must admit that my mouse
was was very slow and because I'm not at
home it was it was a bit complicated to
play but ok I mean I mean of course I
lost not because of the mouth but
because I just made too many boners you
said you're traveling right visiting
your parents and so you're not at home
and you're in your normal set up the it
did seem that way I mean I don't think
it's an excuse I think it did seem that
there were some time scrambles where you
were you were you were struggling more
than you would but do you feel like
psychologically it was just hard to
recover without a break after that game
where you played rook a 1 and blundered
the rook was it was there a tipping
point at some point where you just felt
frustrated about
meaning yourself uh yes yes I I was
about to talk but what okay I mean I
tried try to to keep to keep it going
and maybe I should have played some more
serious chairs and in some point i i i
wanted to to get fun to to get some some
some creative just way and but maybe I
should have played more seriously I mean
just to try to show the best result I
mean I don't say that I was not trying
but but maybe some more CDs opening well
on that note let's uh let's transition
to you young Christoph congratulations
you uh you shock the world with this one
you played phenomenal chess and what was
your approach in the opening you seemed
like you were prepared to play mainline
mainline weapons whenever given the
opportunity to and really had it going
today tell us a little bit about how you
felt did you feel the practicing this
week helped you to feel comfortable in
the format and what are your thoughts
and what do you attribute the victory
today till well I think I played this
five plus one very poorly because when I
had many time problems and in general it
could be better but watching last match
period on TSN I okay I've seen that
bullet is very important that I thought
that if I play bullet more then then I
will have some chances well okay
okay I think this baton is crucial
because I think I was winning
practically every game but this last one
well actually I didn't know much theory
okay I just played everyone might cut
here but well I decided to enter in this
endgame because looking in this position
of 33 I couldn't find anything decided
is just better to to step into my fury
yeah in the beginning I was very
stressed but then okay I want this by
like the second game and realized that
okay like is also part of the game
especially online chess yarn Christophe
it seemed like you and Sergey we're
switching off victories with the white
pieces I mean you guys won I think like
12 games in a row all with white it was
that play a factor in you switching your
opening into the French because that was
something that you know caught us by
surprise
yes actually I wanted to play this
position support before kinesics in the
first game in the first game I played
before by excellence because I wanted to
play 96 of course give me a territory T
but well actually I applied this French
in classical games oh yeah ok ok I also
didn't do much time in service
Cillian ok I think it's interesting to
play quite not so much fury and
ok play the positions but I was scoring
it's cutting poorly in so panic so I
switched to French
actually I focus on my chest mostly the
shorten the shorter the time was then I
have less time to thing and just to play
chess but that's why I think this last
one was very poor in my body I played
this poorly okay then I had then after
in the bullet and 3+1 the beats I just
played okay in the first game I forgot
properly there was one because I started
to fought for a very very long time in
the same game but I was lucky to win
this because for those who young
Christoph could hear me I apologize to
the twitch yet I asked him he told me he
told me before the match that he was
nervous and he said that obviously you
heard his answer is the time controls
got faster and he played quicker and the
nerve shook off and trusted his
intuition he did even better so sorry
about that but my question was about his
nerves that he admitted to me before the
match so Robert I don't have any other
questions besides a big THANK YOU to
Sergey Karjakin and young Christoph for
bringing us the the most exciting match
we've had so far again an incredible and
incredible finish I know Sergey it
wasn't your wasn't your favorite result
but obviously you both delivered for the
fans we had we had donations to your
prize fund throughout the day because of
some of the brilliant moves you guys
played and just a huge thank you and a
huge congratulations to you young
Kristoff it so before you go I have to I
have to ask you what do you what do you
need to do to to repeat this success
you've had today against a sir gays
fellow countryman an Olympian teammate
Sasha grig Alexander grishnak is who
you'll be taking on to the next round
what are your thoughts on what you need
to do in that match to have
another victory over another former
world champion okay I will try to do my
best of course well I think that in my
case it's best not to think too much
just to play chess by hand by things I
know that it's very good in this you
haven't played any classical game
exactly but I mean but you'll have
you'll have fun and do your best
yeah I feel like you're giving an
inspirational speech follow your heart
and let the chest be your vest right
there you go well thank you both Sergei
again thank you so much for for joining
us even while on vacation visiting your
parents
we appreciate it thank you to young
Christoph and and we wish you wish to
have both of you back next year and
young Christoph we will see you in the
next round thank you thank you bye guys
well Robert just me and you now looking
at the bracket and the rest of the fans
you know get to predict along with us
we've got every second round match up
set besides the one that will see
tomorrow with onigiri versus chakra are
Mahmoud yaar off I cannot wait for that
but I am just I'm just mind blown right
now blow it away
final final thoughts Danny I'm just
gonna say it one more time because I've
been saying it all match I said it
before the match to our statisticians or
prognosticators I have tremendous
respect for a young Chris Taub do those
play I've seen him many of his games in
you know especially in recent months but
you know in the last couple years is a
tremendous talent I didn't think he was
the big underdog that many purported him
to be and I'd liked his answer at the
end he sounded like he should be in a
Nike commercial because his thought was
sensuous just do it and you know we'll
see how it fares against Alexander
Grichuk I know before that I'm ik super
excited for the match of tomorrow
between onigiri and Jacques beer mom
Jarrah I see mommy jars the 13 seed
playing before but I think that mama
Jarrah is the heavy favorite and the
seeding is misleading
well that rhymed so good job on that I'm
gonna disagree with you I say that I
think onigiri has a lot more experience
on our server and is hungry after barely
losing last year to Wesley so and I'm
gonna take onigiri so should be fun
tomorrow we will see all of you tomorrow
make sure you clear your Friday plans
it's not that big of a deal to call in
sick and make sure you're here your boss
would totally understand Robert thank
you for flying alongside me here and
thank you everyone for being here we
will see you tomorrow bright and early
10 a.m. Pacific 1 p.m. Eastern and
whatever time that is and wherever you
may be across the world good night
everybody
you